bonjour à tous Dans un instant vous
allez pouvoir suivre une table qui s'est
tenue la semaine dernière au Sénat dans
le cadre des travaux de la mission
commune d'information sur le sport
professionnel la semaine dernière les
sénateurs ont entendu les présidents des
liges de sport professionnel ces
derniers sont intervenus lors de cette
audition pour dire l'importance des
collectivités territoriales dans la mise
en place de projets sportifs et lors de
cette audition clairement pu entendre
deux voix d'une part la voix des
collectivités via celle des sénateurs
qui sont intervenus pour dire que trop
souvent la fréquentation des stades
était insuffisante pour justifier la
construction de nouvelles infrastructure
d'autre part on a entendu les présidents
de ligu de sport en salle notamment
présidents de handball de basketball ou
encore de volleyball qui ont dit
l'importance de construire de nouvelles
infrastructures pour pouvoir
concurrencer
les clubs étrangers tout de suite donc
retour à cette audition qui s'est tenue
la semaine dernière au
Sénat très bien Madame et messieurs
bonjour je vais pour ouvrir cette table
ronde vous
faire une rapide présentation déjà des
des travaux qui ont été réalisés par
cette mission donc cette mission commune
d'information sport professionnel et les
collectivités territoriales a été créé
début octobre et a tout d'abord entendu
l'ensemble des associations d'élus
locaux cette commission euh s'est
ensuite intéressée au nouveau modèle
économique du professionnel et notamment
la question du financement des stade et
leur place dans la cité
elle a également réalisé plusieurs
déplacements euh le premier à la
Fédération Française de Tennis ensuite
est allé à la pour rencontrer les du
basket mais aussi les concepteurs de la
future 92 d'autre part nous avons
également aussi été reçu par la
direction du
Saint-Germain enfin la semaine dernière
nous avons organisé une première table
ronde dans seconde table ronde avec
l'ensemble des présidents des grandes
fédérations du sport
professionnel const c'est qu'il ressort
de ces échanges que l'implication des
collectivités territoriales dans le le
développement du sport professionnel
demeure importante même si une tendance
nouvelle se fait jour dans certaines
disciplines qui voit émerger des clubs
qui souhaitent financer uniquement grâce
à des capit privés les relations entre
lestivités territoriales et le sport
professionnel reste donc complexe et
riche dans certains cas l'intervention
publique est indispensable pour
permettre et on l'a vu à en à un club
euh d'arriver au niveau où AR plentaire
au niveau un titre de champion de France
mais aussi une participation en Coupe
d'Europe mais pour permettre
l'émergence et le soutien
de de certaines épreuves comme on l'a vu
avec le Glob challenge mais d'utres cas
les collectivité ont le sentiment d'être
moins des partenaires que des
contributeurs nets n'ont pas toujours
leur Moot à dire on le sait les
collectivités peuvent être enrôlé dans
le financement de nouveaux stades qui ne
correspondent pas toujours à des besoins
pérennes qui n'ont pas fait l'objet d't
préalable suffisamment rigoureuse comme
ce fut le cas au ou à Grenble elles
peuvent être plus que de raison aussi
ces collectivités pour adapter les
équipements sportifs à l'évolution
deation ou au besoins des diffusurs
audiovisuels
elles sont trop souvent encore appelés à
combler les déficits des comptes en fin
de saison sans avoir vision claire de
l'utilisation de ces fonds publics il y
a donc toujours un besoin de de
transparence qui se fait sentir non il y
a donc aujourd'hui besoin de
transparence qui se fait sentir mais qui
ne remet pas en cause l'intérêt que
peuvent avoir les collectivités
territoriales pour le sport
professionnel mais force de constater
que l'émergence d'un sport spectacle
souvent très élo de l'éthique du sport
si l'on pense à l'évolution de la masse
salariale de certains clubs pose aussi
la question de la légitimité l'invention
des collectivités locales de l'équité
des
compétitions comment dans ces conditions
pourrait-on améliorer laation de ce
secteur afin de lui permettre de se
développer
harmonieusement autre question comment
préserver l'alléa sportif qui est un
fondement de la légitimité de
l'intervention
publique agiliser les
investissements enfin qu sont les
besoins des clubs qui poursuivent pour
poursuivre le développement que ce soit
en terme d'équip de
form pour discuter évolutions don je
vous remercie
madame
présence
monsieur ligue
nationalejsur
Jean liue nationale de
volleyball
monsieur président la lition de
basketésassociation
générale Jeanpierre directeur général de
la liue nationale
de
de football excusez-moi je regardais
monsieur Capon et
je monsieur jeierre directeur général de
foot professionnel et
monsieurti directeur général de la Ligue
nationale de handball que nous
félicitons encore pour le très beau
succès de l'équipe nationale le weekend
dernier en finale du championnat
d'Europe donc mesdamesames et Messieurs
je vous propose donc de cette table
ronde d'achever nos travaux autour de de
17h nous avons nous pourrions commencer
par vous laisser la parole à chacun 5 à
7 minutes
pour vous situer dans le cadre de cette
mission après je laisserai la parole
rapporteur Stéphane Mazard qui aura une
série de questions à vous
poser bien
sûr le débat sera ouvert puis les
sénateurs de la mission poseront leur
tour aussi le questions je vous rappelle
que nos débats sont filmés et diffusés
en direct sur Internet et qu'
organisé sur le compte officiel du Sénat
Sénat direct alors avant peut-être de
vous présenter je vais plutôt demander à
mes collègues sénatrices et sénateurs de
se
présenter Michel deine sénatrice du
Nord Stéphane Mazard sénateur de laavon
rapporteur de la mission Aline Dufau
sénateur du
Vaucluse
jeanmarieenbergur du pas de
Cal
monsieuron vous avez la parole on
commence par
vous
merci directeur général de la Ligue
nationale de je tiens avant tout à
excuser l'absence de Philippe Bernard
qui est retenu par des obligations à un
de nos clubs de division et qui ne peut
donc être là aujourd'hui euh je tiens
làabord vous vous remercier de de cette
invitation c'est toujours un plaisir
pour nous je pense pouvoir parler au nom
de de l'ensemble des ligues de pouvoir
échanger sur
euh les questions qui nous tarudent les
les problématiques qui sont qui qui sont
les nôtres
euh liens entre le sport professionnel
et les clubs comme vous l'avez for
justement euh SP justement souligner
sont sont très euh très nombreux on
parlera j'imagine
d'infrastructure sportif de d'aide publi
de partenariat public également et de
beaucoup d'autres relations qui sont qui
sont très importantes au jour le jour
pour pour les clubs
de compréensions peuvent
exister avec les avec les collectivités
locales euh mais il faut il faudra aussi
souligner les nombreuses bonnes
pratiques qui peuvent être relevé et les
succès dans de V
partenariats qui se sont engagés entre
les
collectivités local et les le sport
professionnel qui font d'ailleurs que je
pense les collectivités locales pour
plupart ne veulent pas abandonner le
sport professionnel et continue à le
soutenir au jour si les relations
étaient si compliqué que certains
veulent bien le dire je pense que les
collectivités locales ce serait
désengagé du sport
professionnel monsieur
allaro
donc je suis président de la Ligue
nationale de
volleyball depuis 2 mais j'ai contribué
à la création te qui a été la 2e ligue
professionnelle en France eu beaucoup de
gens l'ignorent il y avait le football
le volleyball est venu créer sa li c'est
nous gérons trois divisions donc une
grosse ligue au niveau club puisqu'on a
aussi la particularité de gérer une
division
féminine 40 clubs en tout et un budget
moyen en ligue am de 1 600 € 550 joueurs
et joue professionnels voilà un petit
peu la problématique et l'état de la
Ligue nationale de volleyball que j'aime
je souhaitais vous faire
connaître merci euh monsieur donc je
Dominique jou premier de la Ligue
nationale de basketball oui bonjour
madame et monsieur le sénateur merci de
nous recevoir quelques mots d'abord
parce que le président de la
NLP Patrick Wolf il m'a demandé de
dire quelques mots sur cette
organisation qui regroupe peut-être vous
le savez les les professionnelles de de
sport collectif les sports de de de
salle le volet le le basket et et de
pleinire avec le rugby et et le football
pourquoi une association telle que la
nôtre ben c'est parce que on a quand
même des problématiques qui nous sont
communes on a une veille législative à
faire on a une veille télévisuelle aussi
à faire puis que même si tout le monde n
pas au même niveau à ce niveau-là il y a
des intérêts pour tout le monde à
défendre et puis un travail évidemment
de de lobbying important aujourd'hui en
amont des des textes euh en amont des
des évolutions et souvent des évolutions
qui vont bien au-delà de notre de de la
France puisque nous sommes confrontés
bien souvent à la concurence européenne
voire voire mondiale mais en ce qui nous
concerne surtout européenne qui est de
temp problématique et bien éloigné de
nos contraintes donc ce sont des sujets
qui nous sont communs et qui sont
souvent évoqués dans cette organisation
enfin je pense que ça a été utile mettre
de mettre cette ces problématiques
communes sur
dansion régul alors au titre de la Ligue
nationale de basquette don je représente
le président Beral était absent
aujourd'hui donc la Ligue Nationale de
Basket c'est deux divisions
professionnelles une pro une pro
de 16 clubs en pro 18 clubs en pro c'est
une un chiffre d'affaires d'environ
d'euros avec une répartition de 50 % de
partenariat privés 30% un peu plus pour
prob un peu moins pour la ProA de
partenariat public c'est dire évidemment
l'impense du partenariat publicite le
reste étant des des recettes dichet et
des recettes autes
ring et autres
euh nous avons mis en place un label
enfin nous sommes en train de mettre en
place un label qui se veut surtout pour
structurer les clubs pour leur donner un
caneva commun et des pistes de de
progrès euh ce n'est pas simplement pour
je pense qu'on y reviendra tout à
l'heure pour donner des contraintes
supplémentaires au aux collectivités je
suis moi élu donc je je suis de temps en
temps des deux côtés de la barrière et
je sais trop combien c'est contraintes
fois son importantes et ont été même
quelquefois exagérées c'est moins le cas
aujourd'hui en tout cas les ligues ont
peu de prise sur ces contraintes souvent
cela vient des des fédérations
ensuite on a euh on est en train
d'expérimenter une piste qui est
peut-être intéressante pour le sport
professionnel euh à savoir les
invitations euh il y a deux modèles dans
le sport professionnel il y a le modèle
de montée et de descend traditionnel
européen franco-français auquel on est
euh d'ailleurs attaché et puis il y a le
modèle de la NBA par exemple ou
américain où ce sont des ligues fermées
on est en train d'expérimenter un modèle
intermédiaire qui permettrait d'inviter
sur des critères euh bien définis
d'équipement bien sûr euh financiers euh
d'organisation du club et de capacité à
mobiliser des partenaires des partenair
privés dans une zone d'achalandise
intéressante pourour avoir un club qui
soit au plus haut niveau et voir au plus
haut niveau européen donc on on on a
ouvert en proie la possibilité à deux
clubs de prober de pouvoir accéder à la
première division par un autre biais que
le biais sportif en travailler avec des
collectivités travailler avec des
dirigeants de club et ensuite il y a
unetion complètement indépendante de la
Ligue dont d'ailleurs il y a des membres
de de ministère des Sports Monsieur
jarich qui était en charge d'un rapport
peu euh qui viennent là de façon tout à
fait neutre pour essayer de voir quels
sont les potentiels de de de tel ou
telle zone d'achalandise ou
agglomération communautés urbaines dans
lesquelles le basket est développé mais
pas suffisamment donc c'est c'est c'est
c'est tout nouveau pour le moment
l'année dernière c'était d'ailleurs
Serge Blanco qui était blan qui était
Président de la
Commission personne ne s'est dégagé de
de cette première tentative l'année
dernière cette année il y a 7 ou h je
crois clubs qui ont candidaté on espère
sortir quelquesomérations enfin en tout
cas deux pour monter la club 18 clubs
les avantages à cela c'est d'abord plus
de matchs c'est une sécurité meilleure
parce que deux clubs qui descendre sur
18 c'est évidemment moins que de clubs
qui descendent 16 et ça répond de temps
en temps au au aux questions posées par
les collectivité lorsqu'elles
investissent de se dire mais si demain
et vous avez cité tout à l'heure
Grenoble
et et le par exemple si demain le club
redescend ne ser sans parler de
problèmes financiers bien évidemment ça
ça ça POS donc c'est quelque chose je
crois que tout le monde regarde avec
intérêt j'espère que cette année on
arrivera à faire émerger de de deux
villes de ville nouvelle sinon il y a
une commission Arena là aussi qui
travaille avec qui travaille aussi avec
le ministère des des sports pour
imposer qu'est-ce que un club
professionnel de basket a besoin comme
équipement pour être conforme euh à ce
qui se fait dans dans dans les autres
pays qui qui sont nos nos compétiteurs
parce que en de mots j'aurai fini le
budget moyen d'un club de basket
aujourd'hui c'est entre 4 million et dei
et 5 millions d'euros euh euh en euh
c'est pas suffisant pour être compétitif
au niveau europen pour être compétitif
au niveau européen passer dans ce qu'on
appelle le Top 16 il faut un minimum de
8 à 10 millions euh donc la marge est
quand même relativement importante alors
on n'est pas dans les mêmes
configurations certainement qu'on en
discutera tout à l'heure et puis le plus
gros problème des sports de salle c'est
qu'il n'y a pas salle en France c'est
c'est juste inimaginable euh c'est un
sujet dont on débat depuis des années
années ici et et ailleurs et il y a
toujours pas de ça dans ce pays quand on
VO se passe dans d'autres pays qui
économiquement d'ailleurs sont plutôt
der nous voilà résumé rapidement merci
beaucoup monsieur donc que
Jean-Pierre française de
football qui qui est retenu
après après avoir participé à la remise
du du rapport de Monsieur glavan à la
ministre à Madame le Ministre des sport
d'un mot le pour le football
professionnel comme vous avez déjà eu un
long dialogue avec la ftion Française de
Football je circonscrit le débat de mon
point de vue au seul football
professionnel les subventions des
collectivités locales les subventions
peuvent paraîtres minimes par rapport à
d'autres sports puisquelle prendent à
peu près 2 % du chiffre d'affaires du
football professionnel c'est milliard
300 millions à peu près de Chi
d'affaires pour une contribution sous
forme de subvention je parle pas des
partenariats de de 2 à peu près des
collectivités locales les clubs sont
évidemment les partenaires de premier
rang des collectivités locales et la
Ligue ent avec chacune des collectivités
qui a un club professionnel sur son
territoire des rapports très très
fréquents je sollicite chacune des
collectivités pour l'élaboration du
calendrier général de compétition pour
vérifier qu'il n a pas de de doublon qui
rendrait la vie compliquée à la
collectivité et à la préfecture nous
sommes sollicités par ville lorsqu'il
s'agit de réaliser des projets par
Madame de mcine avait bien voulu
sollicit la la présence du président de
la ligue son équipe lorsque le projet de
stade avait été préfiguré à Lille et et
grâce à elle nous avons pu rencontrer
des des citoyens lois qui se posaient
questions du sport professionnel et leur
donner les réponse que nous pouvions
leur donner au cours d'entretien qui
était très riche de la même manière il
que nous entretenons relation
particulièrement dans avec certaines
collectivité sur des sujets ponctuels
par on a passé pas mal de temps
avec pour que les je et Cestres mondiaux
se fassent dans des conditions qui
préservent la vie du club mais qui ne
gênne pas l'organisation qui est menée
par par le GIP pour les Jeux équestres
mondiaux de la même manière avec mon
équipe on est allé un certain nombre de
fois à Basti rencontrer les élus locaux
faire sorte que laation de des clubs
locaux au championnat se déroule dans
des conditions qui satisfassent toutes
les parties donc on beaucoup de contacts
qui sont des contacts approfondis avec
les collectivités et où tout le monde
preuve je crois d'une extrêmement bonne
volonté d'une très grande naissance des
des dossiers du sport professionnel en
tout cas du du football euh pour pour le
reste l'évolution que vous indiquiez
monsieur sénateur tout à l'heure c'est
bien celle d'une très progressive
appropriation ou tentative d'intérêt
privé sur les enceintes cette évolution
elle se fait d'une manière qui n'est pas
encore
très qui qui qui est assez divergente
selon les opérations l'euro 2016 qui
sera une réussite au point de vue
rénovation et construction de nouveau
stade sera peut-être plus compliqué à
analyser en terme de progrès dans les
protocoles ont ses équipements avec les
opérateurs les grands les grands
opérateurs comme leses les club et les
collectivités donc des modèles qui
seront relativement simples comme celui
de l'OL il y a des modèles plus
compliqués celui que connais bien que
vous connaissez bien madame sénatrice ou
des des modèles comme comme ceux de qui
qui qui de l'OM et de
mais dans l'ensemble il y a
effectivement une tentative de
professionnaliser aussi l'occupation de
ces enceintes sur le sur le long
terme sur la question des normes qui
préoccupent particulièrement votre
commission c'est la fédération qui aimit
les normes il y a là aussi un dialogue
notamment dans le cadre de la licence
club mais depuis bien avant son
existence avec les collectivités lorsque
les services de la Ligue les commissions
de la Ligue estiment que tel ou tel
stade mérite une amélioration de ses
équipements il pas d'exemple que que ce
soit des mesures unilatérales prises par
la Ligue que ce soit dans le domaine
sportif ou dans d'autres domaines une
discussion approfondie avec les
collectivités mon expérience c'est qu'en
général c'est la collectivité qui
souhaite avoir la vie de la Ligue pour
mener les travaux en relation avec le
club quel que soit le mode de
financement retenu et qui souhaite avoir
de la part de la Ligue l'expertise
qu'elle peut donner ça n'est pas la
Ligue quiance va imposer à des services
te souvent très étofés et parfaitement
capable de lire les règlements euh des
des ouases donc dans l'ensemble les
relations avec les collectivités sont
des relations qui du point de vue de la
l des relations constructives euh elles
sont euh organisées par des textes que
tout le monde euh a l'obligation de
respecter notamment la vie du
conseilétat de 2003 qui a fixé des
règles claires en matière de de de
desdtions normes le football les autres
sport professionnel va vers un modèle de
label licence euh pour l'action
dans des conditions qui sont ensuite
financièrement balisé aux
compétitions évolution est une évolution
lourde et qui inarrêtable qui d'ailleurs
présente de grands avantages dans
lesquels l'ensemble des clubs se
retrouve mais ça ne veut pas dire que N
ser tourn d'une manière ou d'une autre
les règles fixées par le par le Conseil
par le Conseil d'État voilà le le climat
donc nous on se trompe peut-être on n'
pas le sentiment en ce football
professionnel d'être dans une sitation
qui est une situation de tension
particulière où les intérêts des uns
seraient bafoués par les autres
connaissance de leur de leur spécificité
de leurs compétence on a plutôt le
sentiment d'un dialogueveau et des des
services de collectivité qui sont
largement à la hauteur de leur tâche de
la même manière que le dialogue les
pouvoirs publics locaux que sont les
préfectures en matière de sécurité se
sont beaucoup développé au cours des des
dernières des dernières années avec des
résultats qui sont parfois spectaculaire
voilà le climat d'ensemble donc après il
y a des problèmes de principe mais qui
sont des problèmes qu'on qui pour
l'instant ne sont que des problèmes de
principe savoir si le sport
professionnel uniquement un spectacle et
qui oublie l'éthique sportive et les
règles d'équité sportive l'expérience
qu'on a la Ligue c'est chaque fois qu'on
serait tenté pour des raisons
économiques de remettre en cause
discuter de questions de relégation
d'accession et de péréniser la présence
régulièrement dans les championnats le
débat ne se nous pas parce que les clubs
ne le souhaitent pas donc j'ai le
sentiment que le sport spectacle ù ça la
professionnalisation euh ne sont pas du
tout le le prélude à la transformation
des des championnats de football en tout
cas en en ligue fermée avec des
franchises on en est extraordinairement
loin en et je crois que ce débat n'est
même pas sérieusement é ne le sera pas
ne le sera pas
voilà merci beaucoup donc pour terminer
donc je donne la parole à Monsieur Paul
Goz président de la digelle de
rugby je
d'abord cette réunion donc je le prés
Lig nationale de rugby alorstionale de
rugby c'est une ligue relativement jeune
puisqu'elle a 15 ans de d'existence elle
compose deux div comporte deux divisions
Top 14 et la D2 de 30 clubs
c'est un la Ligue à budget de 80
millions et qui passera 120 millions
l'année prochaine d'euros euh et le
chiffre d'affaires global du championnat
professionnel Top 14 D2 et environ à peu
près 350 millions
d'euros donc euh en ce qui concerne les
relations avec les collectivités c'est
surtout les clubs évidemment qui ont qui
ont ces relations plus que la Ligue
puisque la Ligue hormis euh
euh projection de stade
euh les contacts lors de de de de de
décisions pour des terrains avec les
collectivités locales et plus
particulièrement à l'heure actuelle pour
les les demi-finales que nous faisons
toutes les deux sur la même ville
pendant le même weekend qui nous font
avoir un contact assz précis avec les
collectivités territoriales de la ville
en question
euh les contacts avec la vi sont surtout
des avec les les collectivités li sont
surtout euh dis sur les problèmes de euh
réglementaire pour les stades ou autres
euh ce qui concerne le le rugby pour
parler et la argir le débat euh comme je
disais c'est une ligue qui est
relativement jeune qui a essayé depuis
le départ de rationaliser euh euh ces
rapports les rapports entre les clubs
euh en prenant des un certain nombre de
mesures comme salicap pour éviter le on
va dire peut-être l'exlosion des des
masses salariales euh qui a essayé de de
de de de faire que laation soit au
centre du débat avec la la nouvelle
proposition pour les GIF hein les les
joueurs ici desres de formation euh avec
un cas un peu particulier pour le rugby
puisque contrairement à à beaucoup
d'autres ligu où la la France n'est pas
premium au niveau des ligues
internationales la France a à cette par
particularité en r qu' est je pense la
Ligue la la mieux organisée et la la
plus valorisée de de l'ensemble des
ligues professionnelles de rugby qui
nous cré des contrats qui sont peut-être
différente de celle des autres ligues
bref pour revenir aux collectivité
territoriales la les subventions que
versent les collectivités territoiales
sont à peu près 3 % du budget pour le
Top 14 à pe PRS 5 % du budget pour la la
euh notre principale problématique pour
les années à venir ce qui concerne
surtout les relation les collectivités
c'est la c'est le problème des on a créé
laab stade un fond stade qui va démarrer
à partir de la saison prochaine nous
n'avons pas par rapport au à la
situation géographique de nos clubs
bénéficier de d'aménagement spécifique
sur les terrain ni pour la Coupe du
Monde 98 ni pour l'Euro 2016 puisque peu
de de de clubs sont dans les villes qui
sont saisis par ces stades donc pour
nous c'est un des objectifs et un des
sujets de de développement de notre de
notre sport des prochaines années et
donc voilà c'est ce que je voulais dire
en
particulier en ce qui concerne le rugby
et je vous dis une une un moment où on
est en recherche de stabilisation de
notre avec un gros effort qui est fait
pour essayer de de réguler je dis aussi
bien par le par les GIF le fait qu' une
compétition qui soé
intéressante on n pas envisager pour
nous notre part le
disait le problème bien sû des lig fermé
je pense pas que ça
correspond du tout à la
mentalité à la mentalité française par
contre on étudie certaines piste pour
essayer de de faire qu' une stabilité
pour que les investissements qui soi
fait puissent ne pas être ne pas être
faitir les années qui suivent voilà en
gros la problématique du du rugby au
niveau de la des relations du rugby avec
les collectivité terrielle voilà je vous
remercie merci beaucoup ben je vais
donner tout de suite la parole à
Stéphane Mazard notre rapporteur pour
les premières
questions merci monsieur le Président
merci à interlocuteur du jour pour leur
présentation
liminire peut-être revenir sur ce qui a
été dit à l'instant par par Monsieur Go
concernant cette idée de Ferm donc vous
dites que vous y Songz pas le foot l'a
dit clairement également alors le basket
j'ai bien compris c'est un système un
peu à chemin entre la Ligue fermée et le
système actuel celui de l'invitation
alors euh si j'ai bien compris de
critères qui peuvent faire que la Ligue
de basket invite en proie donc euh un
club émergent et qui a envie de
s'inscrire dans dans le paysage du euh
la question que je me posais que je vous
pose euh si un club descend un club qui
pour le coup aurait fait des
investissements
ant s'il des et que donc l'équilibre
économique du club est mise en danger
par par les infrastructures qui ontagné
l'ension du club et donc se retrouve
aujourd'hui en situation décente est-ce
que dans votre situation vous le
repêchez alors la réponse était l'année
dernière elle est non cette
année pourquoi parce que on a vu tout de
suite l'effet d'OB que ça représentait à
savoir des clubs qui se trouvaient en
situation un peu difficile présumé
difficile à Noël par exemple présenter
un et et à ce moment-là ça rentre pas
dans les critères qui veut que l'on
recherche des agglomérations un peu
nouvelles pour accompagner des clubs qui
sont émergents dans la division
inférieure mais qui n'ont pas réussi ou
ou dont les collectivités voudraient
aussi àagner des privé pour être le plus
vite possible au niveau on va dire on va
citer Marseille par exemple on va citer
chalonrin on va citer rouan on va citer
on va citer voilà voilà des
agglomérations qui représentent demain
un potentiel pourre compétitif plus au
niveau européen ça n'a pas
d'intérêt qui sont Boulazac même si ces
gensl présentent une un dossier il
rentent pas dans les critères parce que
c'est pas une zone d'achandise
prioritaire pour ce l'intérêt ce qu'on
considère êre l'intérêt du basket de
demain je peux juste compléter peut-être
la la réponse par ce que vous disz en
fait a conservé les les
alléas cette année pour que ça soit bien
bien cl il y a que les les clubs de Pro
B actuellement donc la 2e ligue qui
peuvent être candidats donc à ça et
Infiné ne pourront accéder à la proie
admettons que des des clubs qui qui
resteraient dans le championnat
professionnel c'est-à-dire qu'il en a
ceux qui sont on a vouluver l'alléa
sportif cette année donc un club de
proie va redescendre on pourra pas avoir
d'invitation ça ne pourrait être qu'un
club qui est en ProB cette année et qui
à minima resterait en ProB l'année
suivante voilà et c'est 0 ou de d'accord
donc Marseille est en probé par exemple
il monte un dossier vous les invitez en
pro la ville par exemple accompagne donc
la montée de son club et finance une
infrastructure sportive oui première
saison en Pro résultat sportifs décevant
il redescend à pro se retrouve avec un
équipement
rutilant ou sauf que comme on est monté
d'abord on on on essaie que le dossier
soit suffisamment solide pour pour que
financièrement et on peut même
accompagner dans la gestion ce club à un
moment donné ça c'est aussi le rôle de
de la Ligue pour éviter qu' un accident
sportif parce que mais ça peut arriver
ça peut arriver nous on a tous en tête
l'exemple dans le football du man noble
euh voilà ù o les collectivités on
accompagné un projet sportif et ensuite
donc les résultats sportifs n pas
rendez-vous les clubs sont descendus et
les collectivités se sont trouvé se
retour aujourd'hui à critères financiers
relativement
important avec un
budget minimum qui se situera dans le
pire cas à la moyenne budget de pro
c'est-à-dire qu'il faudra c'est tout un
ensemble de critères auquels il faut
répondre et qui donne quelque part plus
d'assurance de rester au plus ha niveau
mais comme on veut
garder notion de descente et de de
montter puisque ça c'est c'est une
invitation qui ne fonctionne une fois
c'est-à-dire monter de 16 à 18 peut-être
de 18 à 20 plus tard s'il y a
d'autres agglomération intéressantes
dans un premier temps c'est deux donc
s'il y en a deux qui montent l'année
prochaine on se retrouve à 18 clubs il y
en a deux qui descendent et deux qui
montent comme chaque année ça ça ne
change pas la règle des monté et des
descentes habituelles mais on a fait
émerger à un moment donné de clubs et on
sécurise quelque part parce que
descendre sur 18 c'est
mathématiquement mieux que 2 sur 16 sur
16 d'ailleurs le rugby en parle avec
Serge Blanco PA est d'accord avec moi 14
c'est compliqué
quoi
comp chaque fois on y laisse un
historique ou deux et ça c'est difficile
ça répond pas complètement à la
sécurisation on est d'accord et pour
complter par rapport à votre question au
niau AR ne sont qu'un critère parmi tant
d'autres et ça sera pas forcément
préondérant j'insiste c'est vraiment
quatre critères il y a des garanties
financières c'est un business plan sur 3
ans donc c'est il y a des garanties
derrière donc justement pour pouvoir
sécuriser et éviter ce qui pourrait
arriver donc le but est pas d'avoir non
c'est des ancrages régionaux et puis que
ça puisse répondre aux objectifs des qu
critères en question Capon pour dans le
sens de la de la Ligue de bas nousous
sommes interrogés la saison dernière
avec l'ensemble des clubs sur
l'éventualité d'un passage à club pour
en arriver à la conclusion que ça serait
souhaitable dans les années qui dans les
années qui viennent euh é et plébisité
un système mlant monté et descente de
nouveau plus un système un peu comme au
basket
d'invitation et pas un système où il n'y
aurait pas de descente du tout sur une
saison ça ce qui poserait des problèmes
d'éthique dans un championnat entre euh
des équipes qui ne
pourrait pas descendre c'est un peu ce
que vous proposz qui ne pourrait pas
descendreut pourrai pourra descendre et
dans ce cas on se poser de problèm de
lourds problèm d'éthique avec des des
clubs qui pourrai choisir de jouer ou
pas jouer une rencontre en étant de
toute façon à la fin de la saison vous
savez que vous nez pas donc si vous
voulez conserver des derbis locaux vous
laissez gagner
l'équipe l'équipe équipe voisine et vous
sélectionnez les matchs que vous voulez
jouer ça pose de lourd problème de lour
problèmethique à notre sens soit on
ferme complètement la Ligue soit on
laisse un système de montée descente
pour toutes les équipes mais on reste
pas entre entre
deux on a moi j'étais pour faire monter
de clubs de plus pour faire bien sûr 2
sur 16 c'est moins que 2/ 14 mais le
problème aussi spécifique au rugby c'est
que après on a problème du nombre de
matchs les matchs internationaux et le
nombre de match championnat sachant que
contrairement à beaucoup de sport on
peut pas jouer de manière très
rapprochée entre match donc autant on
peut faire des match à handb et en
basket et voir en foot assez rapproché
euh même dans certains championnats
mondiaux et européens chaque soir nous
euh à moins de 5 6 jours entre les
matchs c'est pas possible donc après il
y a un problème de date donc on est
plutôt sur le fait de de de d'étudier
éventuellement une un moins grand nombre
de descentees de Top 14 vers des2 et par
contre pour faire émerger là aussi des
des des des villes qui sont euh pour
l'instant euh dans des régions où il n'y
a pas de professionnel ça se siturait
plutôt l'idée de réflexion avec la
Fédération situe plutôt au niveau de la
2e division
avec une une une montée spécifique de de
certains clubs sur dossier qui ferait un
championnat entre eux au niveau de la F
pour monter à D de donc monterai
championnat part au niveau de la
Fédérale 1 certain nombre d'équipes qui
sur dossier pourrai être admise à monter
dans le SP professionnel quand où ils
arriveraient à réussir don c'est plutôt
vers cette idée content sachant que la
bien sûr le problème comme je disais
tout à l'heure de ligue fermée n'est pas
envisageable pour ce qui est du du rugby
voilà un peu les les dilemmes dans
lesquels on est donc pour l'instant des
descentes un peu trop importantes par
rapport au nombre de clubs une
difficultémenter le nombre de cont des
matchs et de la de la du récupération
entre deux matchs et donc plutôt une
approche pour
développer les zones où il y a moins de
sport professionnel de sport rugby
professionnel euh niveau de la D2 en
provenance de la Fédérale démoné un
petit
peu sorti du contexte général pour ces
équipesl
voilàppor quelques observations pour le
puisque le cas du Man et on été cité le
problématique dans lequel notamment Le
Men est tombé c'est une problématique
qui malheureusement dépasse le cas du
football c'est problématique du PPP des
stipulations de ces de ces contrats qui
sont compliqués
euh donc l des travaux de la laavanille
ce dossier a été mis en exerg comme
l'exemple même des des des de décision
imprudente de la part d'une d'une
collectivité
le la préconisation qui est contenue
dans a été déposée aujourd'hui devant le
mil des sports c'est qu' y a un espèce
de réseau informel de conseil qui pu
donner son opinion sur les les les les
les lesers et les opérations collectives
qui sont qui sontterminé je suis pas sûr
que qu'une collectivité n'est pas les
moyens de réfléchir elle-même au contrat
je pense les
collectivités on largement les capacités
techniques intellectuelles de déterminer
si un contrat peut les mettre en cause
gravement ou pas mais de toute façon il
une évolution dans la gestion des
équipements difficultés par le
comportement les grandes entreprise qui
gère la plupart des des stades dans ce
genre d'occurrence dévelppe de plus en
plus ement de tour c'est qu'ils ont un
plan d'occupation pluséel de leurs
écrans qui est totalement justifiable le
le Stade de France dans une ambiance
publique a exactement la même
préoccupation mais il nous demande par
exemple de de de prévoir un calendrier
des plusieurs années c'est struc
impossible parce qu'on ne sait pas quels
sont les clubs qui vont être admis en
championnat donc on est amené à des
logiques qui sont contradictoires entre
les intérêts de la colleité l'intérêt
des clubs l'intérêt du du du
gestionnaire de l'équipement donc tout
ça n'est pas stabilisé il estment
beaucoup plus simple effectivement
d'avoir une ville gestionnaire direct ou
un club gestionnaire direct que d'avoir
ses interventions triparti mais ça dit
c'est le modèle qui a été retenu pour
des raisons de de gestion de financement
et
cetera dépasse du football le cas du M
est effectivement un cas qui a qui fait
tâche dieu merci il existe d' l'air de
de
fonctionner difficilement mais de
manière correcte avec des clubs qui sont
stables des des gestionnaires
d'équipement qui r les objectifs des
villes dans les finances pas m en cause
c'est quand même la grande majorité des
projet même est très malheureux et pour
la Ligue la
fédérationours des actions juridiques
encore en cours cet
exemple est un exemple
unique pour pour
reprendre sur la thématique des
infrastructures justement donc dans le
cadre de notre mission le président a
rappelé donc on s'est beaucoup intéressé
sur ce
nouveau recherché aujourd'hui par les
clubsel au travers soit la propriété
soit la gestion
ou en tout cas une participation à la
gestion donc de l'infrastructure vous
avz indiqué tout à l'heure notamment
qu'il y avait un défaut pant de salle
grande sallle qui permettent
effectivement aujourd'hui donc d'asseoir
des clubs résidents et de permettre leur
développement le foot donc va être va
être quand même satisfait par par le
programme de l'Euro 2016 et le rugby on
sait qu'il y a des projets qui émergent
pour essayer d'améliorer les les
d'accueil des
compétitions à chaque fois qu'on nous
présente donc ces divers projets que ce
soit dans les sports de salle ou dans
les sports plinaires on nous parle d'un
modèle économique repose sur le sportif
luimême mais comme vous dit sur
également donc donc capacité d'acueillir
des grands
spectacles alors à chaque fois on est un
petit peuur parce qu'on se dit quand
même que si tout le territoire est
maillé de grandes infrastructures qui
permettent donc d'accueillir les grands
concerts les grands artistes ils se
démultiplient pas et on n'est pas
certain effectivement que tout le monde
y trouve son compte donc ça c'est
première réflexion que je livre à vos à
vous euh
ensuite ensuite est-ce que véritablement
en France il y a un potentiel public
même pour le secteur sportif au même
titre que ce qui se passe en Angleterre
pour le football ou ou en Allemagne on
sait par exemple que dans ces pays
lorsque les clubs sont derniers du
classement voire même en Ligue 2 ou en
D2 ben ils continuent à à accueillir
20000 25000 300 spectateurs qu'on y va
en famille qu'on y consomme et ceter il
y a vraiment une culture du du du du
spectacle sportif et et et du et du
match qu'on a peut-être pas encore en
donc est-ce que tout cela a bien été
analysé par par les clubs euh et puis
euh question concernant ces
infrastructures c'est euh polyvalence
est-ce que véritablement un stade peut
accueillir des spectacles avec les
problèmes de calendrier qui peuvent se
poser vous vous connaissez le calendrier
donc des matchs que vous allez jouer sur
une saison en fait que les clubs jouer
sur
saison juillet euh quand il faut faire
venir un grand AR bien souvent c'est un
an de 3 ans à l'avance qu'il faut qu'il
faut s'y prendre euh donc est-ce que
c'est véritablement crédible euh et
est-ce qu'on peut parler aussi d'une
polyvalence entre sport c'est-à-dire que
est-ce qu'un stade de foot peut
accueillir du rugby de façon récurrente
est-ce qu'on peut imaginer que s'il y a
une
superposition du haut niveau football et
du haut niveau rugby on pourrait avoir
une seule et même enceinte financée par
la collectivité pourquoi pas mais à ce
moment-là donc il rendrait service à de
clubs résidents bon pour les sports de
salle peut-être que ça pose moins de
problème mais c'est vrai que sur le sur
les sports de de pleinire on a de tout
on nous dit que c'est possible puis
certains nous disent non totalement
impossible bon déjà parce qu'il y a des
problèmes de contraintte de euh faut
faire coincider deux calendriers et puis
on dit quand on est vraiment dans le
très haut niveau qu'une plusous de
football peut pas supporter
effectivement contraintes posées par par
la pratique du rugby voilà donc sur ces
trois réflexions concernant les
infrastructures stes leème polyvalence
le problème de du maillage du territoire
euh le problème
de de que je dis de la cohabitation voil
donc sur
réflexion sur la première question vous
avez posé pour l'expérience du
volleyball on a une ville c'est
ja cont 450 personnes 600 maximum ils en
sont aujourd'hui00ve nelle salle
potentiel public je voudrais pas citer
àion je suis persuadé aussi qu'avec une
salle beaucoup plus grande ils auraient
le potentiel public répondant à la
question lorsqu'on est obligé en Lig
masculine de faire jouer un Arbon avec
un potentiel 500 spectateurs je suis
persuadé qu'bon il y a beaucoup plus
spectateurs qui irit voir le volleyball
et je parle pas de chumon ou en C
d'Europe il oblig de se décentraliser
pour aller discuter des rencontres donc
je pense il y avait la structure sale et
je crois que avec le BHV comme on nous
appelle unu péjorativement il y aurait
moyen de s'entendre après c'est une
questionification c'est sûr si on se
retrouve avec trois clubs professionnels
du BHV dans la même ville ça va mon
problème je crois que quand tour
d'horizon il y a pas tellement de cette
cohabitation je crois que c'est un c'est
un objet qui nous manque et surtout pas
parler de Paris où j'ai du mal à
organiser les finales du championnat
France parce que il y a tellement de
d'activité pas de salle que je sais pas
où je vais me décentraliser
ouis sur le problème du public on
s'aperçoit que le le problème de de de
la capacité des Français du public
français à occuper les stades et à les
remplir on s'aperçoit que bon c'est un
c'est un phénomène de culture mais ça la
culture elle est faite justement pour
évoluer on s'aperçoit que nous-même dans
notre sport on est passé on a triplé à
peu près les les affluences dans les
stades sur les 15 20 dernières années
donc ça pe on peut en travaillant faire
en ce qui concerne la cohabitation bon
sport de pleinir le football et
nous il y a de deux écueils majeurs le
calendrier bon celui-là il peut
éventuellement s'étudier en étant
extrêmement pointu après le problème le
deè c'est la pelouse alors la pelouse
c'est c'est un problème un peu plus
délicat mais bon on peut toujours
imaginer que si on fait une
infrastructure on faire de pelouses on
pe on peut faire un système de pelouse
rétractable qui
interchangé ça paraît compliqué mais ça
peut être une solution s'il y a une
seule infrastructure à place de deux
dans une grande ville bon donc voilà ce
qu'on peut dire mais c'est vrai que la
cohabitation de deux clubs
professionnels dans une même enceinte
pose le problème des matchs
pose le problème de du fait que quand
dans un stade que vous êtes résident
vous avez un certain nombre d'habitudes
un certain nombre de de de de de mise en
place qui seront à partager avec notre
club et bien sûr vous êtes obligé
d'avoir des centres d'entraînement
séparer pour que chacun vive sa vie dans
les semaines c'est pas absolument
possible on peut pas dire que c'est
possible mais c'est relativement
difficile si c'est de manière continue
alors dans dans certaines villes vous
avez des stades comme à Toulouse qui
servent au football et qui servent aussi
au rugby et qui servent au rugby par
intermittence et non pas enue je la la
la cohabitation enue de deux clubs
professionnels de haut niveau bon
impossible il faut jamais dire quel
chose quelque chose est impossible mais
c'est ça paraît assez compliqué je je je
sais pas ce qu'en pense le football mais
ça pe paraît être là la conséquence
comme disait monsieur Goz on a
l'expérience de ce partenariat qui est
parfois très compliqué le monde de rugby
en France n'a pu se dérouler grâce au
fait qu'on a modifié notre calendrier
laisser les clubs les les équipes
nationales jouer dansun certain nombre
de stades de football qui ont été donc
gelés pour cette opération on l'
évidemment fait avec plaisir même si
c'est un peu compliqué le le calendrier
après il y a eu des problèmes
effectivement de remise en état des
terrains mais bon le championnat cette
année s'est déroulé normalement malgré
la contrainte de la Coupe du monde dans
le sens inverse la l'oration de l'Euro
2016 en France va entraîner unbre de
difficultés pour pour vous président
puisque les TER terin de
football sur lesqu à partir du début mai
il n aura plus de possibilité d'utiliser
les terrains dévolu à l'Euro 2016 du
tout jusqu'à l'arrivée effective des
équipes nationales en France donc ça ça
se prépare il y a des équipes de de
gestion des calendriers à la LNR et à la
LFP qui sentend du merci bien et et qui
savent qui saventer ça de la même
manière on est en concurrence assez
régulièrement fédération ligue et et
rugby pour l'utilisation du Stade de
France en fin de saison pour les
dernières manifestations de la fin de
saison avec parfois l'un d'entre nous
oublie de réserver le stade à la bonne
date et cetera et donc on a des
discussions parfois un petit peu
compliquées mais finalement quand même à
dérouler nos final dans les bonnes dans
les bonnes conditions donc je je partage
totalement l' du Président je crois que
la organiser des événements ponctuels
avec un minimum de de de souplesse
etation c'est parfaitement possible
organiser une cohabitation de deux
modèles qui sont assez différents au
point de vue public probablement normees
de sécurité et conditions d'accueil du
public pratique sportive problème de
pelouse très compliqué c'est
probablement peut-être plus facile mais
pas les PA dans les sports de s il y a
sans doute des possibilités de
polyvalence je vois assez mal un modèle
de polyvalence continue même si comme
dis c'est pas un possible dans le entre
le football et rugby la magnifique photo
aérienne mant jambois et et et le Parc
des Princes montre d'ailleurs o où on où
on en est bon en tout cas je crois que
l'expérience pctuelle marchera
l'expérience permanente n peu de chance
de prospérer et c'est pas ce que
souhaite probablement d'ailleurs point
de vue accueil du public même les les
les municipalités et les
préfectures monsieur Capon ou
effectivement je rejoignis Jean-Paul
alorau pour dire
que la possibilité d'accueillir
plusieurs sports une même
salle de sport Sal et
euh est envisageable c'est envisageable
d'accueillir plus plusieurs plusieurs
clubs résidentss dans une même salle et
des exemples existent notment notamment
à Toulouse où le
volet cohabite dans sal de manière très
très très très régulière et on
d'ailleurs mise en place une solution de
sol plastique assez assez ingénieuse euh
j'ajouterais également euh qu'il est
parfois plus difficile de conjuguer euh
des spectacles euh avec des lourdeurs en
terme d'installation et de temp
d'immobilisation d'une salle euh parfois
très très long euh sur des activités qui
sont sans doute plus rentables
d'ailleurs que plus bénéficiaires que
des sports de salle avec des calendriers
qui s'envisagent très très à l'avance
comme disait Jean-Pierre tout à l'heure
il est parfois donc plus difficile de
conjuguer une activité de spectacle avec
une activité de une activité de de sport
les en tout cas c'est les exemples qu'on
peut avoir euh nous le nous le prouveent
d'autant plus que les ligues la Ligue de
rugby et la Ligue de football
collaborent dans l'établissement de leur
calendrier nos trois
nos l'établissement de leur calendrier
lorsque les clubs des clubs utilisent
salle pour justement harmoniser ces
calendriers et permettre une totale
fluidité la tenue des des
championnats merci Monsieur G oui la
question de la crainte du public je
crois qu'il y a beaucoup d'exemples ù
passe à une autre et on s'aperçoit que
finalement le public se cale au
capacités de la salle évidemment
proportionnant à la
population
moi d'abord choquant comm en France on
peut peux le redire mais c'est important
que vous le sachiez 12 salles en Espagne
de plus de 12000 spectateurs 10 en
Allemagne deux en en Lituanie deux en
Slovénie pour voilà bon pas en France
Merci qui est aujourd'hui en en
réflexion pendant 3 ans la plus grande
salle c'est po avec
7005 et monelier avec 8000 voilà bon je
veux dire c'est c'est quand même
inimaginable pays comme le nôtre ensuite
moi ma ma conception d'organisation du
sport elle est pas la même selon qu'on
est dans une région où il y a de grandes
agglomérations où là on peut avoir en
parallèle dans la même zone de
population des sports qui peuvent être
un donné concurrents parce que parce que
le gâteau est large parce que
économiquement il y a du monde parce
qu'il y a du public ces pays c'est des
grandes agglomérations ensuite des
régions où où il y a quelques villes de
moyenne importance prend la région la
Bourgogne par exemple j'ai toujours dit
moi dans dans notre région qui fallait
regarder à mutualiser et à un moment
donné à mettre autour de la table les
élus de cesation de regarder où est
l'histoire de chaque sport dans la
région et à un moment donné de façon
peut-être un peu cooheritive pas très
libéral mais à un moment donné il faut
peut-être se donner les moyens de répond
répondre à certaines questions de dire
et bien parce qu'historiquement le
basket est là le rugby est là parce qu'
une équipe dirigeante parce qu'il y a un
public parce qu'il y a despart derrière
et parce qu'il y a une collectivité qui
veut suivre et bien on on considère
qu'on va mutualiser le rugby d'un côté
foot de l'autre le basket d'un côté le
de l'aut parce que il y a un moment
donné finalement et ça ça se pratique
dans d'autres dans d'autres nations il y
a un moment donné en esttant concurrence
et on tire tout par le bas la
collectivité s'épuise le public s'épuise
et surtout les partenaires
pour lesquels on doit et vous avez le
dire sécuriser aussi le projet sportif
parce qu'il y a pas que les
collectivités il y a aussi le partenaire
et l'entreprise qui dit moi je m'inscris
avec ce club dans la durée et et je
passe un contrat avec lui sur ce qui
permet au club d'avoir une visibilité et
bien si on lui donne pas les moyens et
un peu de sûreté à un moment donné et si
on dit pas tel sport est à tel endroit
dans une région bien c'est compliqué à à
gérer je parle pas des grandes
agglomérations je parle des régions et
en France on a beaucoup de régions de de
de de ce type-là donc regardons le
paysage alors quelques fois il y a des
problèmes effectiv politiques il y a des
problèmes d'entente mais essayons de
dépasser ça parce que ça va bien au-delà
de de de de de la vision partisane qu'on
qu'on peut avoir à un moment donné et et
et et c'est un sujet dont on a discuté
depuis longtemps du mal à avir à voir le
jour parce que mais peut-être que les
contraintes économiquestivité et
l'ensemble de la société aujourd'hui
nous amènera à à mettre ce sujet sur la
table
je passe la parole à an duf ou merci
président bon monsieur Julio vient de
dire un petit peu ce que je voulais
dire je surt aux problématiqu lié au
sport de salle au BHV comme
effectivement c'est un constaton a tous
fait nous sommes un pays qui manque
cruellement de de capacité entre 5 et000
c'est pas ce qu'il faut ce qu'il
faudrait pour assurer la polyvalence
trois disciplines moi je suis convaincu
que que ça attirait davantage le public
quand belles installations belles affich
sportive vous avez plus public et en
plus il y a plusieurs disciplines vous
pouvez mixer le
public le basket pe all avir du
volet pas il sagit que laffiche soit
intéressante c'est toujours les même
public moi dans les salles alors bien
évidemment je crois que c'est vous les
ftion les av la vision de de l'ancrage
local que et et les positionnements
idéals qu'il faudit trouver idéo pardon
et et c'est peut-être vous qui devait
faire passer les messages
aulectivité le tour de table on
estonneur je prends l'exemple de ma
ville que je connais bien j'étais au
sport je je sais très bien que on aurait
une grande salle les tris disciplines
seraient représenté sans difficulté on
en ferait monter certain d'une division
il a pas de problème et j'oute que pour
être beaucoup plus précis sur l'allusion
qui é fait sur le mixage avec des
spectacles ça pas de
problèmele
les
diff
merci je reviens sur ce que vous évoquez
tout en ce qui concerne les dotations
directestion directletiv local au sport
professionnel vous nous avez donné des
chiffres tout à fait symptomatique
c'estàdire que le pourcentage est très
faible m à disposition financement des
investissements sur les équipements
sur 2% 3 4%
5% c'est minime mais ce sur les
territoires quelquefois pour les mêmes
collectivités ça s'additionne puisquil y
a plusieurs clubs professionnels sur sur
le même territoire mais que vous avez la
répartition justement entre les
différents échelons l'intercommunalité
la ville le département la région si je
dis ça c'est parce queossible qu'à un
certain moment on arrive à une situation
où les collectivités je parle notamment
des départements et des régions auront
des compétences exclusives he c'est le
débat des mois qui s'ouvrent donc ça
veut dire que si on veut se maintenir au
même niveau de subvention directe des
collectivités il faudra que l'une se
substitue à l'autre hein c'est la la
question que je pose donc de la
répartition et puis deuxième question je
qui re ce que je viens de dire
d'ailleurs c'est le rapprochement qu'on
peut faire entre le débat que vous aviez
tout à l'heure c'est-à-dire le fait que
vous êtes dans une phase de réflexion
pour essayer de concilier euh l'aléa
l'aléa sportif la GL certitude du sport
hein donc la nécessité de maintenir des
montées et des descentes et puis d'autre
part la nécessité aussi d'introduire une
certaine forme de sécurité ou de
sécurisation notamment pour les
collectivités à partir du moment où les
collectivité où les clubs ont réalisé
des investissements importants ça c'est
la première réalité la deuxième c'est ce
qui se passe chez nous je dir au niveau
législatif c'estàdire dans le cadre de
la la modernisation de l'action publique
territoriale on a vu récemment le
renforcement des métropoles est-ce qu'on
nit pas le sentiment que à moyen terme
moyen terme ça peut être 10 ans 15 ans
20 ans mais on ne s'achemine
euh alors il peut y avoir des aspects
positifs peut y avoir crainte aussi tout
à l'heure vous parlez de zone de chalent
dis de PO économique financier et cetera
est-ce qu'on va pas s'acheminer
justement vers des clubs professionnel
de
métropole il va à Paris la loi nous dit
13 métropoles euh euh ça n'a pas que des
avantages parce que quand vous regardez
la localisation géographique de CESR
métropole vous apercevez que vous faites
le tour de France en réalité qui a un
grand vide au centre puisquil y a aucune
métopole pour tout le centre Orléan Châ
rou euh Poitier euh Limoges cler
monferin et cetera ça sera pas des
métropoles puisqu'il faut 400000
habitants ou alors être au centre d'un
bassin urbaine de 650000 habitants
comment AG
Guer bien donc euh est-ce que vous dé
pas ce timent qu'on va s'achaîner
notamment pour des raisons financières
vers ces des cl de de métropole dans les
15 20 ans qui
vienne juste sur pour rectifier un petit
peu pour
lelectivité c'est c'est peu pour les
salle c'est év beaucoup plus ça c'est
une chose mais c'est la force du foot et
du Ruby d'avoir su créer cet intérêt là
c'est le c'est le les vision qui
évidemment font je sais pas combien je
pas parler à leur place mais une part
prépondérante du budget en quelque sorte
nous la télévision
c'estlectivité si si je peux résumer
résumer les choses chez nous alors après
l'ulation 70 % globalement 70 % la ville
ou l'agglomération et et derrière c'est
en gros 15 % avec une
pension très nette de voir les
départements se désengager à part
quelquesuns parce que là il y a des
disparités incroyables sur le territoire
et et 15 % de la région où on peut
retrouver à mon avis des mares manœuvre
si par ailleurs on est
complètement basé sur la formation parce
que c'est quand même une une des
compétences pri de la de la de la région
à savoir d'accompagner la formation et
là il y a une réforme forme importante
pour nous que l'on travaille à
l'association c'est la possibilité de
percevoir la taxe d'apprentissage dans
les centres de formation alors qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé on a vu et et et et on
nous dit que dans la prochaine réforme
ça ne serait plus possible on a vu des
CFA des du sport
mutualiser des ressources de la taxe
d'apprentissage che le cas en Bourgogne
avec des pôles autour de de club phare
basket chez nous rugby dans d'autres
endroits de faç à percevoir cette axe
d'apprentissage et à pouvoir quelque
part abonder la formation tout au moins
les cas futurs de de la formation si
demain on nous cette possibilité ce sont
des financements très importants qui
sont fléchés sur la formation qui vont
disparaître et on connaît l'intérêt de
la formation et et les résultats de la
formation dans les équipes nationales
donc c'est un
sur lequel il va falloir être
extrêmement prudent dans la réforme de
la formation
professionnelle j'ai un peu divergé mais
c'est sujet d'actualité je crois bien
pour pour
vous complètement
d'actualité voilà ens je me souviens
plus ah la méop les métropoles toutçon
vous savez y pas nous qu'estce qu'on
fait on encourage un peu ça puisquon dit
on va aller crer dans des grandes
agglomérations parce que on a envie
d'être compétitif européen donc quelque
part on alimente cette chosef on voit
bien que de toute façon on a plus de
chance d'être champion de France à Paris
boulazak ou à CH sursone même
si c'est comme ça alors est-ce que c'est
bien ou pas bien je
sais conc les métropole bien évidemment
c'est c'est une tendance forte là nous
sur et si cette dernière saison on a
perdu un très grand nombre de villes de
de moyenne importance je cite 14x
montsan montauan Albi La Rochelle bon
tous ces clubs sont maintenant des deux
donc tous ces clubs ont été remplacés la
plupart du temps par des villes d'une
d'une
impance beaucoup plus forte que que ces
villes là donc c'est une c'est une
tendance très très
forteon il y a des les fortes chance que
la prochaine lion monte dans Top 14 don
enc une de moyenne importance donc c'est
une tendance forte qui je pense par
rapport au problèm
économique va
euh va continuer sur les prochaines
années c'est qui concerne les
pourcentages de des collectivités c'est
à peu
près 60 % les mairies 25 départements et
15 les régions ce qui concerne les
financements dans les clubs de de rugby
donc voilà qui représente comme je
disais tout à l'heure 3% Top 14 5% D2
point de vue des par rapport au
budget la
télévision tout ce qu'on peut
représentant queour
deiable mais
15 le nouveau contrat 15 pour 15 à 20%
budget
maximum
donc le RO est différent même avec
l'excellent dernier cont signé avec le
groupe
Canal dans le football recettes
télévisuelles représent à peu près la
moitié du chiffre d'affaires du
football la répartition les
collectivités est très variable en fait
on a refait le tableau avec tout à
l'heure et il y a des certaines
collectivité utilise de manière
coordonnée au maximum les plafonds d'
publi en terme de subvention et
atteignent le les les les donc ils
concentrent les efforts sur un club par
exemple à Montpellier il y a d'autres
endroits où c'est très divers dans
l'ensemble ce sont les communes qui
effectivement participent le plus à
l'effort de subvention ensuite les
régions puis les sur la formation puis
les les départements donc en fait quande
les fournis par la la DNCG PRS
consultation des des documents
budgétaires des clubs il y a une très
grande disparité d'efforts selon les
collectivités certaines ont une action
coordonnée au niveau régional mairie
général région général région d'autes il
vont en ordre dispersé avec des taux
d'intervention très très différen sont
des documents qui n'ont rien deel et qui
peuent la Commission on vous donnera
évidemment sur le point des métropoles
là je suis sûr que l'histoire récente
prouve qu'on a une grande capacité de
contrôle des des montées des descentes
et de puisqueon a perdu lance qui était
un endroit rêvé pour avoirun grand
public de de football on a vu
disparaître l'est de la France
Strasbourg des championnats
professionnels qui étaient
invraisemblable en terme de d'intérêt du
public par rapport au football on peut
dire qu'on a on est inopérant en terme
d'orientation des métropoles à grand
public des des des des projets sportifs
la raison elle est claire c'est que ça
dépend avant tout non pas d'un choix
stratégique que ferait une municipalité
mais investisseur
d'y aller ou pas la renaissance du
football à T c'est Olivier Sadr et
l'effort qu'il a fait pour animer son
club en important d'ailleurs pas mal de
de techniqu marting d'accueil du public
inspiré du rugby c'est c'est les cataris
à Paris c'est investisseurs russes à à
Monaco donc ce sont des des opportunités
saisies ou pas par des des gens qui ont
les moyens financiers de se lancer dans
ce genre d'affaire qui perturb la carte
parfois ça tombe sur une grande
métropole parfois ça tombe sur une
métropole
d'importance comme Monaco et parfois ça
tombe sur des cas où le club situe très
bien dans le championnat sur la longue
distance comme
toutans que plus correspondre à une
logique culturelle et à une histoire
très dans dans sur ce site là donc je
peux dire que je sais pas si le
renforcement administratif budgétaire
financier urbanistique de métropole
suffirait à faire en sorte que les
projets des investisseurs se concentrent
sur elle j'en sais franchement rien sur
le point de la balance sécurité
compétition je crois qu'on s vous avez
raison monsieur sénateur il y a
effectivement une balance à
établir on a étudieré mais vous le
modèle américain de l'administration
rooswelt il a été mod collectiviste qui
l'avantage de la pérenité il a
désavantages il est totalement
inacceptable non seulement je crois dans
ambiance sportive française mais aussi
pour la FIFA ou ou l'UFA il existe des
modèles mixtes par exemple au Japon il y
a bien des relégations et des accessions
en nombre important entre la la première
et la 2è division mais il n'y a pas de
système de relégation de la 2è division
vers les
championnats amateur donc il existe des
possibilités très franchement je crois
pour les prochaines années nous
resterons dans en France pour le
football dans un cadre classique même si
certains de d'autres sport preuve de
plus
d'imagination en tout cas les tentatives
notamment de mon Président pour poser le
débat de la réduction du club à 18 pour
des raisons économiques en Ligue 1 et en
en tout cas et pour des raisons aussi de
facilité du calendrier et cetera
non ass poli des clubs et je crois qu'on
aurait du mal à choisir le moment où les
18 qu'on a envie de garder dans telle
ligue sont réunis alors la réflexion que
certain pr club on qui est intéressante
c'est dire si nos droit tél
deviennent rattrapent un peu le retard
qui est en train de avec les Ligue
allemandeanglaise italienne peut-être il
faudra augmenter considérablement les
anités de relégation pour qu'un certain
nombre de clubs his qui disparaître
professionnel soit aidé à remonter
rapidement ce qui le modèle anglais qui
effectivement fait en gros les Anglais
jouent avec tout le temps leurs grandes
équipes en première ligue pour l'instant
unit de rélégation qui existe ne sont
visement pas suffisantes permett à des
clubs historiques étant chargé de
structures très lourdes à financer
commeance d'être sûr de revenir très
vite et donc ça des contorsionsag au
propriétaire ou créanciers
pouririnvestisseur extérieur pour
réaliser ce projet là on en est
là pouration de
volet subvention représente 63 % en
moyenne des budgets d'un club de
volet donc on a une dépendance aux
subventions comme le foot peut avoir une
dépendance au droits télé comme l'a dit
rappelé Monsieur J toute dépendance de
toute manière pour une entreprise sur
sur une ressource particulière et
mauvaise et nous tentons de de de
réduire ce ratio dans les dans les club
de volet notamment à travers le labelv
qui contrairement à ce qui peut être dit
n'est pas des contraintes
supplémentaires pour les collectivités
mais une aide à la structuration et la
professionnalisation des clubs
d'exemples plus le ratio de dépendance
subvention d'un club de volet sera
moindre mieux il sera valorisé en terme
de points dans dans ce label nnv nous
souhaitons que les clubs soient moins
dépendants mais en même temps nous ne
contrôlons pas les subventions octroyées
au club ce sont les collectivité qui qui
le
décide et on peut rien faire contre un
contre un contre un maire ou un ou un
conseil général qui souhaiterait
soutenir hard un club de volet qui des
fois est le seul club de haut niveau
dans dans dans sa ville ou dans son
département c'est
tout merci une une
question pour revenir tout à l'heure
sur ce que
certains vous avez cité le
et s moi je connais un peu plus le
le dossier de de
grenuble lorsquun club
accède en Ligue 1 14 en proie est-ce que
la
Ligue impose au club certaines
règles en terme d'aménagement
d'équipement pour accueillir les
compétitions aussi bien en terme de
compétition mais aussi les problèmes
médiatiques pour accueillir l'ensemble
des médias télévision et autres est-ce
que il y a obligation de se mettre dans
les règles rapidement où est-ce qu'il
serait pas possible aussi d'attendre
peut-être donner euh qui monte 2 à 3 ans
euh pour être sûr d'une certaine
stabilité sportive avant de demander à
ces clubs de seainor eux se retour à
collecité et en disant voilà on nous
demande deux est-ce que c'est la LI ou
les fédérations qui sont les
les les d d'or dans cette situationl euh
les ligues non
très clairement non d'abord je crois qu'
une je croisès précise qui qui dit que
on pas du tout
autorité des normes
simpl quand un club
monte s'il veut s'assurer d'une pérenité
dans la division où il monte
l'équipement doit être à minima
acceptable pour pouvoir avoir les
accueils des partenaires privés
nécessair et et l'intérêt aussi de des
ligues professionnelles avec deux
divisions c'est aussi préparer les gens
dans l'antichambre lorsqu un projet
sportif lorsqu un projet humain lorsque
les collectivités sont derrière pour
petit à petit accéder à la division
supérieure sauf comme j'ai dit tout à
l'heure mais ça c'est bien particulier
et se préparer à être prêt dès qu'on est
au plus haut
niveau parce que c'est vrai quand on est
prêt et c'est vrai quand on n'est pas
prêt on on n'est pas sûr de s'y
maintenir ça ça c'est clair on a quand
même plus chance de s'y maintenir si on
a préparé ça dans le temps si on a une
salle qui a été pas forcément agrandie
mais remodelée avec des accueils de
partenaires à côté on peut pas
aujourd'hui dire au
club les collectivités vous accompagnent
moins et pas leur donner les moyens ou
donneent les moyens de pouvoir
accueillir des partenaires privés lors
des matchs ou faire les cocktails ou
faire des soirées ou des choses comme ça
je veux dire
c'est alors il y a quelquefois le club
qui monte d'un seul coup parce que il
est monté d'un seul coup parce que il a
été bon pendant une année et qu'il est
monté bon et qu' a pas la structure en
face TER par exemple prenons le cas de
nire c'est un Dr
absolu ça marché pourquoi parce que
collectivité derrière
quiens sa personne qui paye
tout qui paye tous les frais support du
club le club quelque part n'a payé que
sa masse salariale son entraîneur et
quelques chose autour si la collectivité
n'avait pas fait ça elle pouvait pas le
club aurait pas pu aller jouer en
eurolleague aurait
pas aller se promener à l'est de Paris
dans à
carpontier bon c'est un cas bien bien
particulier alors la ville a décidé
euh de de d'agrandir le stade mon avis
la bonne décision prise c'est pas la
peine de faire quelque chose de
gigantesque mais de grandir pour le
porter à 4 ou 5000 je crois c'est ça
3005 ou 4000 ce qui est pas beaucoup
mais bon
voilà s'ils peuvent le faire dans
l'été ça donne des capacité à NRE de
pouvoir continuer pas forcément sa
progression en tout cas de se stabiliser
en proie moi je fais Paris aujourd'hui
que si demain n'a pas cette salle dans 2
ans ils sont morts parce que c'est comme
ça parce que c'est pas possible
autrement parce que on peut pas vivre
éternellement de
subvention sans les recettes guichet et
sans les recette partenariat c'est pas
possible en tout cas c'est pas le modèle
d'un sport professionnel
adulte c'est c'est c'est c'est difficile
c'est cruel c'est tout ce qu'on veut et
puis en plus c'est pas équitable rapport
aux autres qui eux on ont à côté de leur
masse salariale
professionnelle 20 ou 30 % de masse
salariale à côté de marketing de
comptable de directeur de parce que un
club il a 10 ou 12 salariés
administratifs donc et des entraîneur
qui payer rémunéré avec des diplômes et
tout ça don donc voilà c'est
c'est je rebondis là sur ce que vous
venez de dire vous parlez d'équité
euh on peut vraiment se poser la
question effectivement est-ce que les
ligue
ont se permettent de juger de l'équité
dans la compétition entre des clubs qui
peuvent avoir des capitaux étrers des
clubs qui peuvent être mieux
subventionnés des clubs dont la
convention minimise la redevances pour
les moyens mis à disposition est-ce que
ça c'est une préoccupation que les
ligues c'est peut-être une préoccupation
touton c'est c'est un axe sur lequel on
a aucune aucune prise et après
tout l'élu local
sanction tous les 6 ans voilà bon il
prend il dit moi je veux ça ça
j'accompagne ça tel auteur estce qu'on
se pose beaucoup question sans faire de
combat d'arrièreard sur lesites sur les
maison culture sur les
espaces où il d'ailleurs beaucoup de
bénévol parce que dans le professionnel
y compris au plus haut niveau savez il y
a beaucoup
de dirigant pour pas dire tous les
dirigeants du sport professionnel sont
bénévoles des fois il sont mes même mais
mais mais ils sont la plupart du temps
bvo pour organiser un match de basket ha
niveau il faut 100 personnes il y a 30
personnes payées les sociétés qui
viennent et il y a 70 bénévoles qui sont
souvent des supports de l'association
qui le lendemain emmèent des gosses à
travers les
départements et les régions donc voyz
c'est toute une architecture donc
l'équité si le maire de la commune moi
peut-être c'estintérêt tout simplement
ou c'est l'intérêt de ma de ma région de
soutenir ça à hauteur t que mon espace
des arts ou que ma maison de la culture
voilà c'est sa responsabilité pourquoi
pourquoi on on réglementerait ça par
moment où déjà dit qu'il pe pas y avoir
plus de subvention sinon c'est des
conventions sinon c'est des conventions
commerciales avec soumis à la TV et
c'est déjà un peu plus un peu plus
compliqué on est contrôlé on est
contrôlé tous les de ou 3 ans c'est pas
compliqué puis la Chambre réionale des
Comptes et puis ENF des rapports vous en
avez
suffisamment donc moi je suis très
prudent sur rajouter des structures qui
deviendra qui chapauterai qui
or moi je voulais dire simplement c'est
que
l'équité c'est une chimère qu'on peut
pas poursuivre ce
n'est rentr un peu dans le système du du
sport américain alors ce moment c'est un
système complètement différent du are
c'estàd des recettes de
tout par le nombre de clubs on organise
la les recrutements de telle
façon bien meilleurs ENF c'est tout un
système qui est fait paradoxalement
d'ailleurs dans un pays extrêmement
libéral mais au niveau du comme c'estàd
l'équité pour que les
résultatsi entre les équipes mais c'est
un système qui d'près moi n'est pas
adapté à notre manière de voir à notre
mentalité je je je je vois mal nous on
essaie de de mutualaliser beaucoup ça
fait beaucoup de discussions ça fait
beaucoup
de négociation et on est très loin bien
sûr de
l'équitééquité com on pourrait la
éventuellement la souhaité de manière
de manière je dire volontariste oui mais
bon je pense que donc la Seu modèle de
l'équité à peu près complète c'est le
sport américain et c'est pas un modèle
qui me semble adapté à l'Europe ça veut
dire des franchises ça veut dire des
gens qui qui ne monent pas ça veut dire
des clubs qui peuvent être un jour à si
on prend la France à l'Î lendemain à à
Nice PERP par rapport à des
investisseurs qui sont intéressés par la
franchise je pense que c'est
complètement en dehors
du système de du système de club qui
régit le sport européen français en
particulier depuis des décennies des
décennies donc à partir du moment où on
on rentre pas dans ce système l'quité
parfaite vous pouvez pas la trouver
parce que vous vous empêcherez jamais
qu'argent à Paris qu'à pépignan même si
je regrette
profondément voilà làdessus qu monsieur
le sénateur pour les sport américain SS
ont été capable de mettre en place ce
système qui un certain de vertu
collective c'est parce qu'il n'y a une
exposition de la majorité des grands
sports américains à la compétitions
international on vas clos de manière
insulaire et ne sont pas exposés à la
compétition de ou d'un club rus et
cetera donc ils vivent en autarciie et
font leur règles et aboutissent
effectivement une très grande très grand
aléa
sportif c'est l'avantage qu'ils en ont
nous il existe dans le système comme
rugby dans les autres li d'ailleurs des
systèmes quand même
de de relative équité c'est par une part
des télé est fait et réparti de manière
égalitaire entre tous les clubs c'est
pratiquement le le cas intégralement 2
et en Ligue 1 une soli parti des Dr télé
et parti de manière égale entre tous les
clubs après c'est la notoriété et après
c'est la performance sportive mais
effectivement il n'existe pas en France
il nexiste pas non plus en Europe et le
faerpl financier ne corrige pas ça de
montant maximum d'investissement que
peut
consortir leeneur d'un club afin de
favoriser les dessins sportifs qu'il a
en tête le seul sport que je vois
d'ailleurs où il y a ce genre de plafond
de dépenses c'est la Formule 1 mais qui
est peut-être pas non plus le modèle
vous conseillerez d'adopter tout de
suite et je ne vois aucun autre sport où
les dépenses soi comprimé afin d'établir
l'égalité entre les entre les parties
donc on on est c'est une évolution qui
est que le que le financier j'assiste ne
corrigera pas le Fire financier aboutira
simplement mieux contrôler certains
apport en sponsoring ou certains
déséquilibrees financier des clubs mais
aucun cas aboutir à ce qu'il ait une
espèce de plafond de masse de dépenses
fixé unilatéralement al par ailleurs il
existe aussi des mécanismes
d'autorégulation lié au fonctionnement
des DNCG dans le foot conur qui
aboutissent à ce qu'un certain nombre de
clubs soi freinés les ambitions de
recrutement et la DNCG veille notamment
à ce que les clubs ne seinent pas
volontairement pour obtenir résat
sportif et à ce qu'il y ait un peu de
raison dans le niveau des dépenses
notamment salarial et à ce que
l'ambition sportive sur une saison ne
mette pas dans des situations financière
impossible le succès est pas tot en gros
plus de la moitié des clubs
professionnels sont actuellement s
contrôle de la masse salariale voire
sous interdictions de recrutement plus
de la moitié notamment pratiquement
toute la Ligue 2 ce qui évite un certain
nombre de de DVE et introduit peut-être
un des éléments d'équité que que vous
que vous
recherchez juste une précision sur votre
question monsieur
c'esténateur sur le le contrôle d'une
évent montée d'un club d'une vision à
l'autre effectivement mon su rappel
c'est un décret qui qui nous interdit de
pouvoir réglementer sur tel ou tel
critère pour pouvoir monter ou pour
pouvoir évoluer au sein de la ligue
outre des critères de sécurité d'ordre
public que le volet ou à mon sens le
basket ne pourrait pas pour pour des
raisons notamment de capacité de salle
et lesissage ne sont pas assez élevés
euh il y a quand même donc la DNCG qui
opère un contrôle des budgets
prévisionnels sur un club voudrait
monter et qui va
éviter Jean-Pierre que le club se metent
en danger lors de sa montée
effectivement la DNCG va contrôler que
la situation net du club ne soit pas
négative pour certains sports ou mise en
lors de la
montée sur l'autre question sur les
subventions je pas le rapport avec
l'équité à partir du moment où la
subvention a été votée selon en toute
égalité respect des procédures et
respect des plafonds donc je vois pas
très bien le rapport des autorités
compétentes pour contrôler cela la DNCG
contrôle elle la production des
documents et que le budgets soi en
rapport avec la production des documents
votés et sur la rupture
d'équité le sénateur d'Avignon
notamment connaî le problème puisque le
club d'Avignon en volé avait été
sanctionné plusieurs fois sur des
problèmes d'équité notamment lié aux
distorsions avec des budgets et les
compes réalisés et et les DNCG de toutes
les ligues font ce travail là et
notamment 50 % des clubs de foot sont
sont sous M salarial
contrôlé au volet on est plutôt aux
alentours de 90 % que de 60 % du coup il
y a un vrai contrôle des dépenses effect
par les
clubsou permz je je reviens sur les énme
parce que ça c'estement contraant pour
collectivité en fonction club descent et
je comprends la question qu'É Michel
sapine tout à l'heure parce
qu'effectivement
euh pardon ça excusez-moi
je Jean-Pierre HUG tout à l'heure nous
disait dans CIS c'est son propos
introductif c'est les fédérations qui
émettent les normes bon il y a une
semaine on était là avec les les
présidents des fédérations représentants
et de moi je crois pas me tromper le
directeur de la Fédération Française de
Football nous a dit c'était la
Ligue il y a des témoins alors
j'ai pour ça la question j'ai évoqué le
cas le cas d'Avignon il y a pas que le
volet mais on on a eu un club qui monté
en première division qui resta qu'une
année qui a perdu tous ces matchs qui
redescendu entetemps 3 mois on nous fait
faire un stade 17000 places alors qu'on
avait un stade de 6000 place ça coûé 8
millions d'Ur et maintenant on en 2è
division on est bien classé c'est notre
niveau
a une moyenne de 1800 personnes
match le citoyen de base qui voit le
stade 17000 plac se
ditestissementsieur la Ligue n'a pas de
capacité d'mettre des normes sportif
c'est la fédération qui fixe normes
d'ailleurs elle a récemment dégradé les
normes pour les clubs de National pour
tenir compte de pression des
collectivités mais a maintenu les mêmes
normes pour la Ligue 2 et la Ligue 1 ce
qui fait que les clubs qui national en
Lig 2 et Ligue 1 auront un écart en
terme de qualité des terrains encore
plus grand combler sur le premier
exercice donc il y a il y a aussi un peu
de cohérence peut-être à avoir en tête
en ce qui concerne les déclarations de
mon de mon collègue de fédération c'est
c'est étonnant puisque une commission
qui fixe les normes de la fédération et
c'est la fédération qui est responsable
des normes sportives ensuite il existe
un travail au niveau de la Ligue de
préparation de monter des clubs où on
conseille au clubs un certain nombre de
choses mais qui vont bien au-delà de
l'aspect stade qui concerne aussi ces
infrastructures humaines c'est ces
critères financiers nous demandons par
exemple des stades qui montent en Ligue
2 ou en Ligue 1 ou et qui passe qui
passe de la Ligue 2 en Ligue 1 de durcir
l'inrastructure humaine d'avoir par exle
des vrais directeur de la sécurité avec
des postes salariés d'avoir des
responsables à qui on puisse pour tenter
de mettre fin auxigan et cetera ETA donc
ça va bien au-delà des normes de la même
manière nous leur conseillons parce que
on a des contrats télévisuels de faire
en sorte que l'accueil des télévision
puisse faire des conditions correctes ça
nécessite ou pas des travaux mais nous
ne fixons jamais d'obligation la seule
contrainte qui pèe sur les clubs dans
ceadre donne un exempleateur lorsque est
remonté en championnat
professionnel le club et la ville
souhait que les travaux soient faits
rapidement on avait un problème
d'échéance par rapport à l'obtention de
la licence professionnel donc on a
dialogué avec le la ville pour qu'un
certain nombre de travaux de première
urgence pas tous mais ceux qui
paraissaient les plus fondamentaux pour
que le club soit en mesure de recevoir
les spectateurs dans des conditions de
sécurité de confort correct à ce que un
N d'infrastructure lié aux joueurs soi
réalisé tout n'a pas été fait à mais
l'essentiel a été fait le club a eu les
autorisation nécessaire il a la
qualification pour rentrer dans un
championnat
prof j'ai eu plutôt le sentiment que que
la enfin que la ville anticipait besoin
du club et avait plus de compétences
techniqu d'ailleurs faut piloter le club
en matière de réation de ses
infrastructures mais aussi son
équipement humain que le club en donc ça
s très bien passé c'est plutôt comme ça
que ça se
passe l'exemple que vous citez plutôt
désastreux d'une surface d'un club avec
un volume de spectateurs n'est plus
possible la Ligue a perdu làdessus la
capacité juridique d'imposer un nombre
de places dans les nous ne Pons pas
l'imposer nous Pons plus l'imposer nous
avons perdu un contencieux face à un
club é expos à des dommages financi
etne plus à fixer ce genre de norme et
puis d'ailleurs après il y a eu les avis
du de Ch nous sommes
encadrés
jurisprud
2003 on était par
sur on peut pas imposer effecement
collectivité donc des contraintes
d'aménagement de stade à des fins
commerciales de confort il n'empêche que
souvent c'est c'est un petit peu
indirect se passe euh alors avec
notamment la télévision puisque si on
n'a pas les Lux suffisant ça pose des de
retransmission alors est-ce que dans le
cadre du contrat que vous passez avec
les diffuseurs euh effectivement il y a
les contraintes qui sont imposées à la
Ligue par les diffuseurs concernant donc
nombre de luxe suffisant dans dans les
infrastructures par exemple donc ça
c'est le premier point et puis peut-être
alors c'est c'est souvent le basket le
basket c'est vrai qu'il y a souvent des
des changements de de configuration
sportive de de l'2 ben souvent ça vient
d' haut et puis après ça s'impose
effectivement à tous les niveaux et ça
oublige souvent les collectivités ben
voir la dimension du terrain de jeu la
configuration des S de sport est-ce
qu'il a réflexion au niveau des des
sports de salle ou des sports général
pour essayer quand même de de maîtriser
un petit peu ces ces règlementation de
jeu pour répondre par rapport à la
télévision il y a pas de il y a pas de
contrainte au club bon bien évidemment
si un terrain n'est pas éclairé
suffisamment santion immédiate c'est que
le club n'est pas télévisé
donc c'est c'est pas il y a pas
d'obligation de contrainte mais il y a
obligatoirement une il y a quelque qui
se passe c'estd que vous êtes MOS tl dis
j'en parle en connaissance de cause
puisqueà perpignen à cause des des
travaux qui ont été faits c'estd que
l'écarage été fait d'abord et les
tribunes ont été faites après il y a des
problèmes de zon nombre et donc canal
est est relativement rétisent à
téléviser des matchs à à Perpignan par
raort ce problème de zone d'ombre qui
qui va être réglé dans les annéesenir ou
dans les mois à venir mais je veux dire
voilà et la sanction c'est que on a
pratiquement pas de match en Prum en
Premium le soir bon donc donc il y a pas
de sanction il y a pas d'obligation mais
c'est une c'est la il s'ensuit ce
problème voilà euh c'est ça la la les
diffuseurs dans les contr visuels qui
nous lient à à à Canal Eurosport
francevant il n'y a
pasexence au niveau par de lux mais la
pratique technologique fait que les
télévisions demande d'avoir un nombre de
lux augmenté par exemple le passage à la
HD a fait que T les diffuseurs dire on
ne peutuser les matchs en conditions
pour le téléspectateur si vous ne
demandez pas au club et au gestionnaires
des des stades de renforcer leur
équipement donc on l' demandé maintenant
ça a été fait dans la plupart des cas
certain dans certains cas ça n'est pas
fait ça a été fait d'une qui n'est pas
qui ne correspond à la demande qui nous
était faite mais en aucun cas ça
entraîné pour le club un déclassement
une relégation il y a pas de sanction
sportive par contre il y a la sanction
qui indqué monsieurement leur lorsqu'il
doit choisir un match premium choisit
non seulement é mais aussi un cadre vous
avez V peut-être les déc du directeur
des sport de de Canal Plus qui est un
qui con son métier et qui indiqué
clairement de l'apparence du stade du
bon remplissage des tribunes qui est
unment qui compte no diffuseur il y a
aussi l'état de la pelouse sa qualité
visuelle sa qualité technique sa qualité
sportive et c'est un débat qui s'ajoute
à tous les autres avec nos diffuseurs la
qualité du spectacleon le proposer donc
c'est une c'est n pas une contrainte
juridique onéliminera jamais une équipe
pour ça mais une pression continue comme
dans T les comme les administrés demande
aux communes d'améliorer les VO de
manière alors en
basket nous on des obligations de
d'éclairage au plus haut niveau qui est
privé qui est
privé donc qui nous impose des normes au
club force au club de se retourner comme
il peut soit il fait ce qu'il peut faire
en matière de vestia en matière de de de
de place de nombre de place dans la
salle en matière de confort de caméra en
matière voilà qui s'appelle l'Euroleague
qui qui est une organisation privé à
Barcelone qui gère tout le plus haut
niveau européen et pire quand on est en
Euroleague nous on l'a été il y a 2 ans
là on n pas de souci parce qu'il y a un
contrat télé et et et les droits
sont il y a des droits et en plus la
réalisation est payée par le diffuseur
mais quand on est dans la 2uxème Coupe
d'Europe qui est une coupe d'Europe
importante la la France pratiquement
seule n'a pas de diffuseur ou des
diffuseurs via la TNT ou via des chaînes
comme l'équipe 21 pour citer quelle qui
veut bien diffuser tant qu'on veut mais
qui ne veut même pas prendre en charge
les frais de diffusion donc vous êtes
obligé de produire des images ça coûte
en gros entre 20 et 30000 € par match 20
à 30000 € par match en sous-traitance
pour fournir parce que l'équipe qui
vient a un signal dans son pays
retransmis quelquefois même sur des
chaînes
nationales c'est dire le retard qu'on a
en France dans l'organisation
télévisuelle euh prise en charge par par
les télévisions par rapport à des pays
mais des pays qui sont y compris tous
les les pays de
l'Est le crash noyard en Sibérie au
milieu de la Sibérie a une télévision
qui se déplace qui se déplace il y a
8000 km qui se déplace pour pour
produire ses images lorsqu'on peut pas
le faire et quand on obligéçon de le
faire on est obligé de leur donner il
nous donne le signal et on leur donne à
eux on est un peu à l'âge de pierre dans
le le sport professionnel en France il
faut je pèse mes mots mais ou je crois
que je vais dire la M chose que mon
collègue du basket et en plus nous au
volleyball malheureusement on a aucune
pression sur les clubs étant donné que
nos diffuseurs ne verent aucun droit
donc j'ai aucune pression même
financière pour leur faire accepter ou
améliorer le Pr ce qu' produisent quoi
comme spectacle il y a des salles où on
peut pas diffuser on est obligé de leur
imposer parce que ils sont en coupe
d'Europe des contraintes mais en
championnat j'ai aucune possibilité
d'influencer sur mes clubs
si je peux ajouter quelque chose oui
merci c'est que suite à l'avis du
Conseil d'État de 2003 au décret qui
s'en est suivi le problème n'est
peut-être pas tant l'absence de pouvoir
normatif au profit des des ligues que
l'absence finalement totale de pouvoir
normatif en la
matière en matière d'exploitation des
des salles de taille des salles
aujourd'hui le les collectivités ne
peuvent même plus se caler sur une norme
quelle qu'elle soit d'où qu'elle
provienne euh même minimum et ne peuvent
pas se réfugier on sait que ça peut être
confortable de se réfugier derrière une
norme pour justifier un investissement
aujourd'hui il n'existe plus aucune
norme en matière d'infrastructure
sportive ce qui peut poser des problèmes
ce qui nous pose problème au au handbal
puisque euh le la Ligue a été créée en
2004 donc après ce ce décret les normes
existantes à l'époque était était très
très très faible le sport professionnel
le handball professionnel n'était pas
suffisamment développé
et donc on se retrouve finalement sans
aucun référentiel sans aucune norme dans
le ball il n en a jamais eu jamais eu
d'où sans doute le retard qu'on pu
accumuler les salles de rball au cours
de au cours de ces années qui tarde
aujourd'hui dans le contexte actuel
notamment économique à se à se rattraper
donc l'absence totale de pouvoir
normatif pose problème à mon sens je
vais passer la parole à notre collègue
Jean-Marie vanenberg oui merci je vais
êre bref parce que ça concerne pas
exactement vos sports mais c'est le le
foot féminin le basket féminin on tombe
exactement sur les mêmes problèmes c'est
coûteux parce que ce sont des villes moi
je suis j'ai été maire d'une ville qui
s'appelle la race c'est une ville
moyenne donc c'est très coûteux si on
veut disputer le rolique par exemple il
y a des norme très très importante qui
modifie profondément les équipements et
tout ça ça pour un résultat évidemment
aléatoire et souvent ponctuel
donc je dis sans sans le concours des
fédérations nationales pour essayer de
Ré réguler un peu toutes ces normes
international ou européennes on n'y
arrivera pas en tous les cas on
narrivera peut-être pas à organiser en
quelque sorte j'ai entendu que c'était
quand même la volonté notamment dans le
basket mais aussi dans les autres sports
de salle d'essayer d'organiser sur le
territoire euh la diffusion en fait de
de de ces sports on sait très bien que
ça passe par le sport professionnel euh
donc euh moi je je je vois que cette
solution c'està-dire une pression et que
vous ne pouvez pas exercer seul en tant
que fédération nationale mais en
essayant de trouver des appuis au niveau
européen et d'arriver à à réguler quoi
euh sur sur le les sports télé j'ai un
exemple très récent avec le foot féminin
le foot féminin veut se développer bon
disent voilà on on diffuse tel match là
s'agit de Lyon haras Lyon diffuse tel
match à telle date sur
Eurosport telle heure
20h45 c'est pas vraiment l'heure la plus
habituelle pour ce type de sport féminin
et seulement votre stade il manque 40
luxe on peut pas le diffuser sur
Eurosport mais on vous l'impose donc il
faut que vous trouviez un autre stade et
cetera ce qui fait une perte de recettes
évidemment pour le club vous savez le
foot féminin vit avec des bouts de
chandelles
hein c'est totalement différent du foot
masculin je dis là aussi on a on on on
prend pas les moyens pour
développer le sport à tout niveau en
France et notamment le sport de de haut
niveau puisque là il s'agit de club de
D1 en foot
féminin c'est sur le
rugby je je j'entends bien ce que vous
dites monsieur Go que vous allez essayer
de favoriser la montée en des deux
d'ouvrir en quelque sorte et de faire
des invitations j'entends ça depuis
longtemps
aras une ville qui a une certaine
tradition rugby qui est assez étonnant
parce qu'on est pas dans le Sud-Ouest on
est même à l'opposé aujourd'hui à Lille
on on on sans aide réellement de la
fédération et de la Ligue je crois que
ça sera très difficile pour vous
d'essayer d'étendre euh en quelque sorte
le marché du rugby et du rugby
professionnel sur l'ensemble du
territoire il est quand même très
concentré aujourd'hui sur le Sud-Ouest
bon il y a Lyon il y a Paris
heureusement mais sinon à ailleurs il y
a des il y a des des des supporteurs
énormément il y a un besoin il y a une
demande elle est pas satisfaite donc je
dis là
aussi là c'est là o où je dirais les
comment dire les collectivités sont
demandeuses mais à condition évidemment
que les ligues ou les fédérations y
répondent pour répondre un petit peu par
rapport au rugby bon on a essayé
justement d'ouvrir puisqu'on a fait les
demi-finales l' à nante cette année on
l' fait à Lille ça sûrement pas ça vous
a pas échappé et en ce qui concerne le
problème des Moné c'est pas des
invitations mais c'est euh un
championnat de monté en fédéral 1 vers
la D2 qui sera organisé qu'avec des
clubs qui sont
euhtion non non la fédéral 1 qui est
dessus dessous la 2e division créera une
sorte de de
compétition que pour les clubs qui
auront les dossiers qui qui auront été
admis euh au niveau des des
infrastructures et finan des structures
stade et financières pour prétendre à la
catégorie professionnelle de la D2 et
donc ces clubs là font un championnat à
part de ceux qui n'ont pas des
structures pour le faire et deux de ces
clubs monteront en remplacement des deux
qui descendent bien sûr chaque année de
de de la D2 voilà je voulais ajouter
quelque chose qui est peut-être en
dehors moi de mais après je l'ai je l'ai
oublié lorsque j'ai on parlait de
l'équité nous dans le dans le rugby on a
essayé je vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure
de faire que on reste dans des des
proportions au niveau du salar cap parce
que on a une particularité qui nous
permet de le faire c'est qu'on est moins
exposé à la concurrence internationale
que que les autres sports puisque on
peut dire que c'est notre sport qui est
c'est la France qui est leader dans
notre sport en matière de budget et en
matière de de salaire donc on n pas
cette concurrence internationale ce qui
nous permet d'essayer là aussi pour
l'équité de réguler le les masses
salariales sachant qu'en plus le rugby
est et le sport peut-être où la la
différence entre les les équipes est le
plus difficile à à gérer c'est-à-dire
que le sport le rugby nécessite que les
clubs soient à peu près de même niveau
que les écarts ne soient pas trop
importants entre les clubs sinon il y a
pas il peut pas y avoir de il peut pas y
avoir de compétition et de match qui soi
intéressant voilà donc on a essayé de le
faire mais on a la particularité n de
pas être soumis à à la concurrence
internationale à laquelle est est soumis
le foot voilà
monsieur fillot oui sur les contraintes
bon vous vous avez raison d'un autre
côté d'abord on est dans un champ de
concurrence européen et que la question
qu'on peut se poser c'est pourquoi est
ce qui est possible dans la majeur
partie des autres pays européens ne ne
l'est pas chez nous pourquoi on a pris
tant de retard donc c'est une question
que tout le monde est en train de se de
se poser et d'un autre côté parfois ça
oblige et ça fait accélérer
des installations certes quelquefois pas
pérenes mais qui sont jamais
complètement perdu lorsquelles sont fait
intelligemment notamment dans les
capacités des salles pour être aux
normes européennes pour faire une
compétition en France la jauge pour
avoir des compétitions internation enfin
en France en Europe c'est 5000 places et
bien vous regardez la taille des salles
il y en a je sais pas combien entre 3005
et
4005 et ça on le répète j'ai fait partie
deux côtés donc je pe parler aisément
depuis des années des années pourquoi
pourquoi on est si frileux pourquoi on
est si frileux c'est c'est une c'est une
c'est une vraie question il y a un
problème de coût mais pas simplement
parce que on sait bien que le coût d'une
infrastructure notamment d'une salle
c'est plus dans le fonctionnement après
que dans l'investissement lui-même même
si l'investissement est important puis
quelquefois on a fait des salles ou des
stades mais surtout des salles trop
luxueuses pourquoi une salle coûte ûte
30 40 % moins cher en Espagne et en
Italie qu'en France pourquoi il faut
aussi si à 7end de gestation pour au
moment où il y a une décision de prise
des fois celui qui l'a prise il est plus
élu comment comment c'est possible pour
tout pourquoi on a un système de normes
et et et de de recours d'appel ainsi de
suite qui fait que enfin des exemples il
y en a plein mais pas simplement le
stade de Lyon des exemples tout simples
de salle pour des raison X ou Y ù un
type il a vu sur depuis son depuis son
balcon et il dit j'en veux pas bon ok
d'accord on est dans un système
démocratique poussé à l'extrême mais il
y a un moment donné il faut aussi qu'on
se pose qu'on se pose ces questions là
et moi je vois quand même des salles qui
ont évolué parce que justement ils ont
été à un moment donné soumis dans
l'obligation de faire quelques
améliorations nous on a on a mis en
place un système qui s'appelle kyotion
qui est un système de de de prise de vue
qui compile un match pour toutes sortes
de destination et notamment pour les
réseaux sociaux et
pour la télévision et bien sur combien
16 clubs en prois je crois qu'on en a 6
ou 7 qui sont pas câblés des salles qui
ne sont pas
câblé on pas
internet enfin au norme à la vitesse
pour pour faire ça je dire ça c'est une
une question pas pas au milieu de de
nulle
part
voilà donc c'est une vra et quand je
parler de mutualisation tout à l'heure
madame ministre dans votre région il y a
trois clubs trois clubs on est monté
nous voir ces trois clubs bon ces trois
clubs vont être il peuvent pasedescendre
puisqu'il y en a que deux qui descendent
mais peuvent être en situation
difficile c'est là où le pouvoir
politique je m'excuse de dire ça mais à
un moment donné son rôle à jouer parce
qu'il paye à un moment don parce qu'il
paye à partir du moment où il paye il
peut avoir à un moment donné son mot à
dire enfin il devrait dans une
agglomération surtout qu on est dans oui
non mais c'est pas une critique c'est
pas c'est pas du tout une critique mais
je dis essayons de trouver un système
qui un moment donné dise mais attz les
amis moi soyons raisonnable quoi soyons
raisonnable je dis l parce que c'est un
peu
caricatural comme
C je vais rebondir
sur vous venez de parler de is dans
certains secteurs peut-être au niveau
des des collectivités je vais retourner
la question vis-à-vis des des trois
sports de salle que sont le basket le
hand et le
volet on sait que le rugby est en train
de réfléchir
sur la construction d'un équipement
propre à géré par la fédération ou la
Ligue par la
Fédération on voit que des clubs comme
Lyon sont en train de construire un
stade uniquement géré et financé par le
club les infrastructures extérieures
sont financées par les collectivités
vous avez parlé tout à l'heure d'un
manque d' d'une infrastructure au moins
sur Paris qui pourrait accueillir les
finales nationales de de vos différentes
compétitions les équipes les les matchs
internationaux est-ce qu'il y a un
travail qui a été entamé entre les trois
activités entre les fédérations des du
de basket volé et des ligues pour
essayer de travailler sur le partage du
portage d'un équipement qui pourrait
être digne de telle
compétition le seul portage que je le
seul portage que je puisse connaître
c'est j'ai entendu parler d'un
agrandissement de la Hal Carpentier qui
serait porté entre
7000 vous êtes associé ou
pas je n'ai entendu que parler on n'est
pas associé du tout je bah vous êtes on
n'est pas associé mais il y a des
réflexions avec avec le hball parce que
le handball a un club maintenant qui
satellite de de du du du PSG il y a des
négociations pour que le PSG
éventuellement demain je dis demain ou
après-demain s'intéresse à d'autres à
d'autres sports donc il y a eu des
discussions on a même fait des
recherches et trouvé des terrains c'est
que la liille nous on a trouvé des
terrains vierge à la périphérie de Paris
et un dans Paris bon voilà euh où la
collectivité serait d'accord de céder ce
terrain à des coûts intéressants pour
que les cataris en l'occurrence
investissent et fassent une salle bon on
est dans un cas un peu particulier on
n'est pas dans un cas de relation avec
une collectivité la collectivité elle
est au milieu quand même et puis après
les infrastructures pour amener les gens
mais mais donc des discussions existent
par exemple à Graveline il va bien y
avoir à dkerer il y a un club quand la
salle sera construite il y a un club au
plus haut niveau basket et au plus vive
auand donc ils vont bien
cohabiter et je me permets de revenir
sur sur la question parce que je je me
permets de la reformuler je sais pas
fait vous de peut-être la préciser euh
ce que veux dire je crois le Président
c'est sur l'exemple donné par le projet
aujourd'hui de la Fédération française
de
rugby de
financer une infrastructure qui sera sa
propriété d'accord euh c'est vrai qu'on
entend souvent le hand le basket le
volet dire ben aujourd'hui il manque une
grande salle notamment à Paris on peut
pas avoir de de projets de grands match
internationaux nos phases finales on é
obligé de les faire dans les petites
salles fait c'est au Rabé ou à berc bon
toutes les difficulté que ça pose euh
les trois FD ou les trois ligues ou les
six ensemble il y a jamais eu il y a pas
une réflexion justement peut-être de
porter aussi un projet privé hein
partagé entre les trois féd ou les trois
ligues sur une infrastructure d'une
grande salle à Paris qui permettrait
donc ben de de mettre de mettre en
commun donc besoin enfin de satisfaire
un besoin commun quoi nous nous on s'est
renseigné avec la Fédération pour
acheter la pour reprendre la salle
olympique de de de Londres qui était
démontable hein bon ça c'était possible
ça coûtait pas très cher c'était de
l'ordre de 12 ou 15 millions d'euros
enfin quand même bon mais sauf qu'il
fallait trouver un terrain quoi
euh voilà puis après il faut trouver des
clubs résidents parce que qu'est-ce qui
fait vivre une salle c'est le club c'est
pas une fédération c'est pas les matchs
internationaux c'est le c'est le club
résident ou les clubs président donc
pour pour trouver dans le même temps des
club résidents un projet commun des
collectivités des partenaires c'est
c'est extrêmement extrêmement compliqué
moi pour ma part je suis pas favorable
au aux infrastructures sportives privées
on peut me tromper je su peut-être d'un
autre
âge en tout cas pour les salles parce
que parce que d'abord je trouve que
c'est
c'est le travail réalien
de de l'État français de ses
collectivités dans son organisation
c'est d'un moment donné de permettre
avec des partenariats peut-être public
privés c'est possible avec des systèmes
de location mais mais je considère que
c'est pas partagé surrement par tout le
monde mais je considère moi
que c'est c'est le rôle de de de l'État
et de la collectivité d'assurer des
infrastructures sportives Mo je peux me
TR je pe on peut ne pas être d'accord
mais j'ai toujours des défendu défendu
cette cette notion là d'abord parce que
il y a tellement de contre-exemples et
tellement de catastroph
que et qu'à la sortie on va quand même
chercher la
collectivité non char après je passerai
la la parole à maè on regarde on regarde
la réaction pardon on regarde la
réaction de la ministre sur le projet de
la FFR je serais très curieux que demain
on proposer pour faire un communiqué de
presse les trois ligues et les trois
fédérations proposent d'avoir un projet
de constr conruction de salle qui dans 3
ans sera donc face à Bercy avec une
construction publique Bercy et une
construction privée des fédérations qui
sont elles-mêmes délégataires de l'État
en face de Bery je pense que c'est c'est
pas possible aujourd'hui c'est pas
souhaitable et ce n'est pas non plus
souhaité par par l'état français après
qu'il y a une consultation une
participation des fédérations et des
ligues voire financière voire financière
puisqueon on la réclame pourquoi pas
être porteur du projet même je pense que
ça serait pas souhaité
Merine je trouve que la discussion est
intéressante parce que un petit peu à la
fois on
débroussaillent un petit peu où sont les
enjeux parce que d'un côté évidemment
les élus se posent beaucoup de questions
par rapport à ces investissements qui
pour certains apparaissent un peu
dangereux ce qui inquiète et en même
temps vous vous exprimez des vrais
besoins et qui ne sont
pas pharaonique ni partant du rêve mais
qui qui qui correspondent un peu au à
l'état de notre mouvement sportif et au
regard de ce qui se passe dans les
autres P européens ça vient d'ailleurs
dans toutes les réunions moi je pense et
ça ça vient assez fort enhiligramme dans
ce que vous dites c'est que au
fond et ça rapport avec les les sujet
des fusions là que vous me renvoyez par
rapport à
lîle moi je pense que un d'abord le
sport
professionnel petit à petit on verra que
son interlocuteur principal -être
l'intercommunalité franchement euh et
alors peut-être le retard qu'on a parce
que forcément les niveaux les attentes
dépendent d'une collectivité de cette
taille plus à part quelques grandes
villes qui sont capables de rivaliser
mais si on veut vraiment quelque chose
de réparti sur l'ensemble du territoire
et qui correspond à nos forces sportives
aussi qui existent sur l'ensemble du
territoire et là on est un peu à la
croisée des chemins parce que les
intercommunalités n'ont pas tout toutes
encore pris vraiment en main la
compétence sportive certains long plus
ou moins enfin euh et et on voit bien
dans ce que vous dites pourquoi c'est
comme ça pourquoi il y a des salles
autant de salles à 4500 alors qu'il faut
à 5000 ce serait bien on se demande
pourquoi c'est comme ça et la raison
principale pour moi à qui est
l'expérience maintenant depuis de
mandats à
Lille c'est que ça manque de visée
sportive de la part des collectivités et
de la part de ces grandes collectivités
qu'il a il y a pas de politique sportive
et donc il y a bien ça qui est à on voit
bien là on se parle et on finit par
s'entendre en se parlant hein et euh je
pense que la solution elle va passer un
petit peu par là et il faudra du temps
parce que ça se met pas en place du jour
au lendemain une vraie visée sportive
partagée à la fois entre les
collectivités le mouvement sportif en
lien avec leur fédération avec leur
ligue parce que tout ça ça fait qu'une
une seule famille et et tout a besoin de
de cohérence et c'est là où on peut
mieux élaborer euh ces ces répartitions
ces fusions qui peuvent rassembler des
énergies au lieu de les disperser et
enfin moi c'est l'expérience que j'ai
alors celle-là je l'ai pas réussie celle
du basket mais parce qu'on on on veut
aller trop vite pour l'instant je pense
qu'à terme ça on y arrivera parce que ça
va s'imposer mais par exemple je l'ai
réussi dans le rugby c'est pour ça qu'on
a une grande équipe maintenant à Lille
je l'ai réussi dans l'athlétisme où on a
fusionné aussi deux clubs qui étaient
égaux et puis qui se faisaient labour
inutilement on l'a réussi dans les dans
les sports nautiques avec le Water poo
avec la natation mais parce qu'on a
travaillé au sein de la collectivité
dans le lien entre ce qu'on a besoin
comme grands équipement puisque c'était
la première voà premier étage de la
compétence mais quel grand équipement si
à côté on n'a pas de Visé de
développement du sport professionnel
dans son territoire et ça c'est bien à
choisir
voilà moi je pense que ça c'est très
important de lancer alors je pense si
les élus vous lancent un appel mais je
pense que vous devez aussi vous le
lancer un appel vis-à-vis des
collectivités en demandant que sélabore
quand même un peu plus qu'aujourd'hui
des des viser des politiques sportives
parce que je pense que c'est là qu'on
trouvera la solution au problème que que
vous
évoquez merci
monsieur je vais lancer un deuxème appel
forcément éloigné du du vôtre c'est à la
lecture des différents rapports qui ont
pu déjà sortir sur le sport
professionnel en particulier sur les
infrastructures je note l'absence
finalement de lorsqu'on évoque les
projets
d'infrastructure on évoque parfois
le la nécessité d'avoir des avis
différents avis pour bétonner son son
son projet des avis extérieurs pour les
collectivités porteuses de ces de ces
projets alors on a vu des des rapports
où on estimait qu'il pouvait être bien
d'aller d'aller à l'élection régionale
pour pour demander un avis sur sur le
projet en cours et jamais je na'ai
vu évoquer le recours aux ligues ou aux
fédérations pour donner leur avis sur
ces sur ces projets là et je pense que
ça peut être des des bons échelot
puisque dans chacune des ligues existe
des personnes fort
spécialement sur sur ces projets qui ont
un œil extérieur peut-être plus lucide
que les clubs en en local sur le
développement à attendre dans les dans
les années qui suivent plus lucide aussi
parce qu'ils ont des exemples d'autres
exemples à travers le territoire et sur
plusieurs années de de de projet
d'infrastructure et c'est vrai qu'avoir
recours au Lig alors on nous a enlevé le
pouvoir autonome normatif on n'y
reviendra pas mais pouvoir donner un
avis sur sur les projets en cours nous
on a quelques exemples on a plusieurs
exemples où je pense que la vie de la
Ligue qui a été qui a été suivi a été
très bénéfique à la collectivité pour
justement le développement d'un projet
d'infrastructure merci Monsieur Julio
juste vous
dites le temps viendra mais mais il faut
faire attention parce que dans les
intercommunalités il y a des des
initiative de prise d'ailleurs par
sous-ensemble d'intercommunalité on voit
bien comment ça ça ça se dessine et
quand des petites infrastructures ont
été faite si demain vous dites on va
régir ce que je souhaite le sport
professionnel à l'échelle de
l'agglomération si ces infrastructures
sont déjà prises il y aura un problème
d'appartenance à la décision qui aurait
été prise et d'identification à tel club
choisit là tel club choisit là parce que
quand on dit tel club ça veut dire tel
territoire
même quand l'île c'est pas très grand
dans la
dimension c'est c'est Denin c'est pas
lîle et c'est pas orchi par
exemple donc il faut aller relativement
vite parce que déjà aujourd'hui quand un
une ville quand une ville a déjà sa
structure comment elle va abandonner sa
salle et son équipe pour aller dans une
nouvelle salle fondu mutualisé avec
d'autres c'est c'est je dis pas que
c'est pas possible c'est un vrai travail
et nous on a fait le tour de toutes les
agglomérations voilà et nous on a fait
le tour de toutes les agglomérations on
a rencontré peut-être le Président il
vous a rencontré à Lille pour justement
accélérer choses pour pouropite
oui non mais le cas mais c'est vrai
partout c'est pas vrai que mais c'est
long c'est long faut 3 ou 4 ans pour
faire ça parce qu'après faut faire voter
les budgets
hein dans une agglomération c'est c'est
avec des intérêts qui sont souvent
éloignés les uns des autres et les temps
vont être
difficiles les temps vont être
difficiles on voit bien dans dans les
propos qui sont qu'on est en train
d'échanger qu'il y a il y a deux
questions il a la problématique des
sports extérieurs ou la problématique
des stades n'est pas un vrai problème
sur aujourd'hui le rugby et et le en
général ont des équipements qui peuvent
accueillir un certain nombre de
spectateurs avec des avec des conditions
qui même assez plus que correctes par
contre dans les sport de Sal ce qu'on
entend mais on entend depuis plusieurs
réunions c'est qu'il y a un manque cruel
d'équipement euh permettant à ces
activités d'évoluer au plus ha niveau
national et au niveau international donc
là c'est un vrai problème d'aménagement
de territoire avec des salles entre 5 et
10000 places mais au moins plus de 5000
places et et c'est alors si c'est la
seule réponse c'est d'attendre des
investisseurs extérieurs c'est vrai que
c'est un petit peu
euh ça pose question donc là tout le
débat à avoir entre les collectivités
mais aussi les les fédérations les
ligues et et l'État sur le financement
de tel équipement je vais laisser la
parole au rapporteur peut-être pour
conclure nos nos
discussions peut-être oui avant de
conclure enfin une impression c'est que
quand on rencontre vos clubs dans la
plupart des disciplines on sent quand
même qu'il y a une demande forte d'être
propriétaire ou gestionnaire avoir
vraiment une même mise sur les
infrastructures il me semble qu'au
niveau des ligues on est un peu plus sur
la réserve alors je sais pas si c'est
une impression que j'ai est-ce que vous
la confortez ou
pas je peux je penser le principe de la
réalité euh moi je suis représentant de
la Ligue mais je suis aussi président
d'un club professionnel si si j'attends
un investisseur ou si moi-même je me
lance dans un dans un montage financier
pour faire une salle bon on en a une
mais peu importe si on avait dû le faire
nous bah on serait mort de de notre
vivant
hein c'est c'est c'est inimaginable et
et même en foot pas parler à la place de
Jean-Pierre mais combien de clubs et
combien d'agglomération ont les
possibilité de faire ça combien combien
ou alors il y avec des délégations qui
font qu'une finé c'est l'agglomération
qui qui met ce qui manque quoi alors
évent ça c'est des montages économiques
qu'on leur limite aussi hein
il est
probable développer un équipement qui
leur appartiendrait il se peut aussi que
pour des raisons politiques les
collectivités d'accueil ne le souhaitent
pas et évidemment et c'est c'est
parfaitement c'est un débat évidemment
qui qui ne peut pas être traité
unilatéralement et puis pour la majorité
de nos clubs la capacité financière
actuelle de leur investisseurs est très
en de ça de ce genre de projet ils sont
déjà en difficulté pour soutenir
l'activité d'un club à des aux
conditions de concurrence européenne
actuelle en grande difficulté donc on a
c'est un autre sujet qui est évoqué dans
dans pas mal de groupes de travail le le
problème général du du du
sous-financement de nos clubs se pose et
se poserait encore plus si on devait
développer de nouveaux projets de stade
dit la conclusion de de Monsieur sain
sur le fait
qu'effectivement les progrès réalisés en
matière de d'équipement de stade et font
que pour le football l'accueil du public
qui se passe quand même dans des
conditions correctes en France
maintenant et qui vont être très
améliorés par les réalisations de l'Euro
2016 et et le constat pour
nous euh oui nous c'est ce que je disais
tout à l'heure en introduction nous
c'est pas tout à fait le le le le même
cas bien qu'on est peut-être pas tout à
fait les murs problèmes que les sports
de salle il faut quand même voir qu'il y
a 5in clubs de Top 14 qui on moins de
10000 plac àass dans leur club alors
qu'on a une moyenne de de spectateurs
sur l'ensemble du championnat de 13005
et comme le le disait
monsieur HUG le le problème des à
l'heure actuelle même si la la le
souhait des clubs peut paraître d'être
propriétaire de gérer leurs
investissement et fa leur stade il y a
peu de de il y a peu de de propriétaires
de club qui qui ont les moyens de
soutenir à la fois le club et se lancer
dans un investissement qui est quand
même extrêmement important pour pour
pour les les budgets de ses de ses
partenaires et de ses propriétaires de
club donc il peut y avoir une forte
volonté mais de euh qui est freiné par
la difficulté qu'il y a à pouvoir
financer ces investissements là voilà
donc euh voilà et nous comme je disais
donc dans nos villes on a pour la
plupart on n' pas bénéficié au niveau
des stades de des des de ce qu' a fait
ce qu' a mené la Coupe du Monde 98 et
aujourd'hui la Coupe du monde le le
championnat d'Europe de 2016 bon euh on
on on en bénéficie lorsqu'on délocalise
nos matchs puisqu'on fait beaucoup de de
de match dans les dans les stades de
foot mais au moin de vue des clubs
résidents ils sont encore dans des
stades don je vous dis un grand nombre
de clubs 5 n'ont pas 10000 places assis
pour faire les pour pour recevoir leurs
spectateur donc chez nous aussi il y a
un travail très important à faire dans
le dans l'amélioration des stades et le
fait que il soit en adéquation avec le
public et comme on le disait tout à
l'heure c'est aussi le le le contenant
qui fait le contenu hein c'est-à-dire
que c'est à part moment où aura des
stades plus importants que quand on
parlait du public qui en France
peut-être euh et moins actif dans les
stades qu' n'est dans d'autres pays
européens on peut aussi se poser la
question des stades dans ces pays-là par
rapport au nôtrre hein quand vous voyez
les stade anglais les stades allemands
que vous les comparer au au Stade
Français dans l'ensemble euh on peut se
poser la question de qui c'est la poulet
leœuf est-ce que le contenant fait le
contenu ou le contenu le contenant donc
je pense que l'amélioration des stades
serait porteur du développement du
public vers le sport
voilà bien madame et messieurs merci
peut-être un dernier mot vous avez été
destinataire d'un
questionnaire si vous pouviez donc nous
retourner vos réponses écrites vos
contributions voilà c'est avec plaisir
que nous les recevrons et que nous les
analyserons et peut-être si vous pouviez
nous préciser alors un élément qui a été
abordé celui donc du niveau des
subventions des collectivités
territoriales au club donc ce soit les
les clubs de première division ou ou de
seconde division en tout cas tous les
clubs professionnels ça voilà on serait
on sera preneur merci beaucoup merci
mesame Madame et
messieurs voilà pour cette table ronde
de la mission commune d'information sur
le sport professionnel les sénateurs
parallèlement à leurs auditions
enchaînent les déplacements ils se
rendront demain au Centre National de
Rugby de marcousi puis ils se rendront
également à Londres ou encore à munique
pour voir comment se porte le sport
professionnel en Europe vous pouvez bien
sû tjours revoir et revoir toutes les
tables rondes sur notre site
publicsenat.fr prochain rendez-vous de
l'actualité parlementaire cet après-midi
à 16h30 pour 24 heh c la séance
présentée par Delphine Girard la séance
sera consacrée à une proposition de loi
socialiste sur l'économie réelle très
bonne journée à tous sur les chaînes
parlementaires
on se souvient de ces adieux
retentissants au revoir mais lorsque
Valérie